okay I'd like to welcome everybody from
our public to the education committee
today um we're here today uh as members
of the committee to look at six bills
which we have retained we've retained a
total of 20
bills um and for your information we
have approximately 109 bills coming to
this committee for the next session and
so we dealt with over a 100 of this and
for committee members you know how much
time and effort that took to go through
that you magnify every bill by two or
three because we have hearings
we have to have exec sessions we may
have work
sessions and it's looking to be a very
very long January and February um so we
have 20 bills that have been retained
six today my goal is for us to try and
work these retain bills out and
hopefully we can we won't have anything
coming out with this 1010
business that was suggested in one
previous sub committee meeting the vote
was a 33 and I said I am not going to
accept that take it back and work it out
folks so that's my intent right now is
try to get as much to the floor that
where we can go in with an up or a down
motion none of this no recommendation
stuff and I think we have retained the
type of bills where we can work things
out um there's some good policy in some
of them and so that's where we are today
the first bill in the docket is
147 we retain this uh it's a bill
dealing with the advisory uh uh Council
for special education and it dealt with
the issue of representation members on
that
Council and for several of us here we
have served on that Council before we
know there's Oodles of people there and
uh one of the the recommendation
contained within 147 just this refresh
pie people was that there's
representation from correctional
facility and and uh we also had the
county there two different
facilities and so uh the motion was to
uh strike the one representative from a
County Correctional
Facility so um that's responsible for
administering this type of programming
in that facil facility to just one
representative of the Department of
Corrections so with that I'd like to
open it up to members of the committee
here let's get some discussion on and
first represent Tanner you have your
hand up yes um after looking at that and
and hearing some input um people have
said that the county is where uh the
representation probably should be
because County correctional officers
deal more with misdemeanors and would um
be dealing more with the age group that
uh we're um interested in dealing with
on this committee so just just as a
comment that I've had come to me I have
since had that same uh
discussion uh in Grafton and we have of
course a correctional facility right
there in haal where I live and um we're
talking about uh a misdemeanor That's A
or B but you can get up to up to a
one-year trip there we have a a a people
in the past we've had come in actually
those that have not graduated they're
carrying an
IEP and we've had to chase down what is
where is the resident District often
times we find it's on the other side of
the county or it's certainly not coming
from necessarily where the person was in
trouble so it's up to those people
deliver that service so I I concur I
understand that the correctional
facility that's on the in the county
level is responsible for providing this
service many times over especially to
people that are residents of our state
so other discussion on that yeah yes
represent B Bon um well I attended I'm
the new representative of that committee
and I happen to attend my first meeting
last night so I do have some fresh
information and I also want to uh I
wondered if we can give uh
representative katab some time as well
um because she is a prime sponsor of the
bill um so from what I heard last night
it's a everything has shifted they've
got a new chair and everybody's um
adjusting one of the problems um with
this committee has been that they need a
parent majority um and currently where
50 51% is required they only have 42% so
they're having trouble uh retaining
parent membership so that has a lot to
do with retain um keeping the Quorum so
when you adjust the number of of
non-parent members you have to
subsequently adjust the parent members
to balance it out um they took a a poll
um it seems that currently the
membership of the committee would like
to keep both representatives from uh
Corrections um the comment that was made
at the time is that they uh serve
different purposes one's more longer
term and one's uh shorter term and um
also that uh they feel that um currently
I was told that the populations from
both of those areas are similar at this
time and um regarding the addition of
the medical uh person
um the although the committee really
would appreciate that um point of view
and perspective it would alter um the
the Corum requirements to add an
additional person without taking off the
other p position um and there was some
talk about um maybe instead of having an
active voting member of the committee
having medical professionals uh with
differing expertise uh come to consult
the committee at other times um again it
was just my first meeting and I don't
know a lot about the history so that's
why I would I was wondering if we could
let representative katab address why the
bill was what I want to do is get some
of the issues out on the table here
first did everybody receive the
communication from Bonnie she's here
also and and uh she's put together a
kind of a history with what CMS she
shows where it's been over the years
with membership and I think I I took
some time I saw first time this morning
Bonnie on on on my email I opened it up
and it was very it's not the type of
reading you want to read before you go
to bed but it is the it is good reading
and informative reading in terms of how
this thing has
developed and how the the council has
developed so now we do have some copies
of that Bonnie brought in 12 I do have
one on here so we have one two three
four so let's let's pass these out if
you have a copy uh you know pass it by
so I'll pass going this
way and
uh we also have a number of folks that
are absent today um and many are are are
due to they have do appointments for
themselves family doctor's appointments
veterinarian appointments uh business
outside the state and with that um I do
not plan on taking any specific action
at the end of this I will take a straw
vot to see where we are in certain
issues so we can sort of like we did on
266 the other
day so does everybody have a copy of
this right
here so before we we get into the
current
Bonnie could you come forward please and
try to just go through that a little bit
with us so that there's a lot that have
not looked at this this is a historical
view of this what happened back in the
days that Nancy Styles Senator Styles
was engaged with making some of these
last
changes
yes
is the red light on or do put no there
you go thank you now it is thank you
thank you um I was curious to find out
when did different committee members
start so I went back and found the 1994
version um and it was interesting to see
how much larger the state advisory
committee was back then when it was
first formed there were members of
Representatives of school up a school
board the commissioner um a
representative from the State Board of
Education and so on and then we weaned
some down over over the years and added
a few so I tried in here to First
include the ones that were consistent
with idea and that have not changed um
and we they didn't start requiring a
majority of parent members on idea until
2004 um which is why in the very
beginning there was a requirement for
seven parents and all of these other
people because it was it didn't have to
be a majority um New Hampshire is much
more specific whereas an idea they say
teachers we say how many teachers and
one needs to be a special education
teacher so we we we're true to our our
general theme of being more clear um the
first two pages are what we already had
whereas on the second page we had a
representative of the business and
industry Association in the very
beginning and then in 1998 it was
changed to one that was involved in the
transition of students with disabilities
but it was kind of similar um we added
the higher education and the um private
schools and the charter schools in 1998
as well um so that more of
the choice options were were available
um and in the very beginning the special
ed administrator was represented by
recommended by the New Hampshire
Association of special ed administrators
and now it's just a special ed
administrator of a public program so
that is again a piece of clarity
um
the one piece that is that we are that
New Hampshire is missing
actually if this person currently serves
on sack but it's not in RSA 186c it was
I think it was removed by accident and
that's on
the next to the last page where idea
requires a representative of adult and
juvenile correctional institutes and we
we don't have a requirement for somebody
from the juvenile correctional institute
we had YDC until 2006 when I believe it
was removed by
accident so you may want to put that
back
um and we've always had the two
representatives from the House and
Senate education committees parent
information center and disabilities
rights Center the last page were all of
the ones that were in
1994 and within the next four years they
decided that that was being a bit too
extreme and they got rid of of those to
lean the committee down a
bit so Bonnie
um you're you're fairly familiar with
the this Council
we have two members from the house and
two members from the
Senate every time we put legislation
together putting together a committee or
some kind we are getting wise and only
putting one Senator because we're lucky
to get one yes um what's the attendance
of of the Senators on on this I actually
did a chart of attendance um several
years ago and the attendance of both
House and Senate is pretty slim um which
is why they typically AR counted towards
the Quorum if they're not there
um I think because people are so busy
and so we sometimes have one of each but
it's very very rare that we have even
two Representatives um and I can't
remember the last time there were two
senators present at a
meeting when I was and I couldn't
present there have been pretty broad
stretches when there wasn't one
appointed um and there was one instance
when um it was rep Jack balom from marac
he was on this committee was primaried
and so he was not reelected and he was
on the state advisory committee but his
term hadn't ended for the state advisory
committee he just didn't exist in the
House Education committee any longer um
and so while it doesn't say it in the
statute informally committee members
from the House and Senate have remained
until removed by the president of the
senate or the or the um com the chair of
the
house yeah Jack was vice chair and he
took over when I got off that came out
Council and yes put jack on he loved it
and he was very very into every issue
associated with special education yes so
um so that's information for the for the
committee are there any thank is are
there any questions of Bonnie here on on
this sheet that she handed
us thank you very much yes represent dry
thank you Mr chairman I just been on a
lot of committees is this a workable
number to get things
done there there have been quite a few
years when quite a bit was done um and
often times people break into smaller
subcommittees and then bring things back
to the full committee so it all it isn't
always
25 people sitting in a room having a
discussion about a single topic from
this from scratch very often somebody a
smaller committee has done the leg work
to bring it to the larger
committee there have been times in the
past couple of years I think Co
devastated the committee um and
particularly when you had to be in
person and have a quorum and many of the
members work with family members who are
very medically fragile and so they
simply couldn't show up and so the state
advisory committee literally could not
get a quorum for almost two years for
that reason um and so couldn't do
anything prior to that I think it was
pretty functional I I think it's
daunting to think about that many people
on a committee especially with special
requirements for majorities and things
like that thank you for you're welcome
you're welome yes represent C cin just
want to double check so does it make
sense in your mind to eliminate one
Senate senator and have one Senator and
then have one representative from
YDC in my personal opinion yes that
makes
sense you wouldn't lose anything because
they don't come
anyway well that's that's what I'm
thinking but yet somebody from YDC can
certainly contribute pretty
substantially yes um and then I had a
second question can have a follow could
I ask a second question well you're
you're you're echoing my mind and I
you all right we're on the same then
after you represent Cornell on it's just
the follow up on the discussion with the
correctional officers so if a County
correctional officer which makes sense
to me because of the you know distance
and what they know in their
regions that that would
be um a
reciprocal position in a sense that like
you had mentioned somebody from Coos is
in Grafton would the Grafton County
person go would the
Coos person go so that they've got some
flexibility on one of them has to be
there versus yes and that actually can
happen because there's contracted
services to send two Graft in
surrounding counties okay all right
thank you thank you for the state prison
it's I think it's extra important
because they
provide uh sentence reduction options
for people who complete a diploma and so
on and if you need special ed and you're
not getting it right you're not going to
complete that diploma and so you have to
stay longer which is really
unfair right we have one of those
represent Cornell you do but yours is
federal
well yeah perhaps Corell when discussing
YDC there's no more YDC it
and and even senuna Center we don't
really know what it's going to be
replaced with at this time for
youth yeah I don't know what the
juvenile correction agency is K
please right under the bus good morning
for the record I'm Karen Rosenberg on
the policy director at the disability
rights Center um I think what the law
requires of someone not from YDC in
particular someone from Juvenile Justice
so that would so I right now our statute
refers to it actually does refer to the
Youth Detention Center not sysc and um I
don't know that that name's changed even
in the the new law that was passed that
will reopen a new facility but regard I
don't think that matters so much because
really it's a representative from
Juvenile Justice Services and that's
what we have right
now I think that's
clarifying any further questions for
either folks that are at the table oh
yes represent
Damon I just like to and thank you for
being here I'd like to hear either of
your perspective on the um additional
proposal to add a healthare provider who
has expertise in working with children I
frankly was surprised that that wasn't
already part of this
group I think that one of the
complications is that depending on the
disability it may be a a different kind
of health care provider so you would
need to have all kinds of people there I
understand at the committee yester last
night Karen was there so I'm I'm one of
the members of the committee
so I mean and I'm not speaking for the
committee I'm speaking for disability
rights center right now um I think the
Challen there are a couple challenges
here one is that we want to make sure
that the committee gets the information
it needs about the interplay between
medical issues that are related to a
disability and education and so the the
committee might address or be interested
in looking at issues related to children
who experience mental health issues or
maybe children with developmental
disabilities or maybe children who have
specific learning disabilities and you
know that are related to dyslexia and so
there are different kinds of medical
providers who could be involved with
those children and having a generic
requirement for a medical provider may
not actually meet the committee's needs
to and and further our objective which
is to advise the commissioner on the
unmet need one of the our objectives on
the unmet needs of students with
disabilities so we may not by having a
generic medical provider we may not get
the expertise that we need on the
committee and then we would be required
to have at least two more parents of
children or students with disabilities
on the committee to meet the 51%
requirement which is really critical
it's very I mean this is a it's it's
very critical that parents of students
with disabilities and students with
disabilities are represented and heard
on this committee and the committee has
struggled to recruit and retain and have
active participation of those members so
you know that the other part of besides
not necessarily getting someone with the
expertise we might need at a given time
we would be needing to recruit even more
parents or students with disabilities to
have a better balance on our
committee interestingly there have been
times when the the educator special
educator or administrator was also a
parent or a surrogate parent but they
didn't count towards the total number of
parents because they were there in the
role of a special ed administrator but
they tended to bring both perspectives
to the table just an extra point of
consideration per
Damon so I appreciate the explanation
I'm
wondering since this healthc care
provider position has not
existed how does the committee obtain
the expertise that you just described
that comes from varying different kinds
of providers I think there's different
ways that we could obtain that
information I don't know how much work
the committee has done in the past on
securing that kind of medical
information do you Bonnie no it really
hasn't come up but if it were to the
committee so we are we can have
subcommittees that include people who
are not members of the sac and that has
happened before so um that might be one
thing to do if the sac chose as a
priority looking for example at the
unmet needs of students with um
developmental disabilities we might want
to consult with a developmental
pediatrician so and and and these folks
are hard to get also right so we could
you know reach out and involve that
person on a subcommittee that would be
one way another way would be to invite
someone to come present to the sack on a
particular issue um that is that has
that overlay between medical needs and
educational needs so we don't
necessarily need to have a
representative on the committee to
accomplish that and get the information
that we
need so could language be followed up
with something like the fact one local
healthc care provider who shall
specialize in working with children such
as pediatrician appointed by the
governor as a nonvoting
member I I I think I don't know I mean I
think it's a little odd to be on a
committee and not have a vote like
you're I don't know that that's a good
precedent to set I think that if people
are making the commitment to attend a
monthly meeting for two hours be on a
subcommittee um they ought to be able to
vote on what you know and on
recommendations the committee might make
so I think it would set an odd precedent
for on the some of the Committees I'm on
which have technical support and as a
trustee with the university system we
have a number of Trustees which are
nonvoting
members but are tremendously influential
in in providing that information when
it's popped up and discussed by the
trustees so it it goes does it does go
both ways as warranted yeah yeah I mean
I I hear what you're saying I'm not I
also don't know how that would impact
quarum if there's a non- voting member
maybe they wouldn't impact the
Quorum that would you'd want that to be
explicit um so that we don't end up in
that whole bind that we've been in when
it comes to voting the Voting is based
upon those which are voting members and
the Quorum is based off of voting
members I mean I I hear what you're
saying I guess that makes sense I I do
think that it would be helpful though
for the committee to look at where you
know what kind of Provider do we really
need where where are we really missing
information and to have a thoughtful
that who had the hand up first here
represent Tanner then representative K
did somebody in between have a hand up
okay goad thank you um I'm just
wondering if there's something that that
can be done either maybe not through
statute but
if if there's some way that we can help
recruit more parents I mean it there
certainly is enough across the state of
parents that are in that situation but
I'm not sure uh whether it's where you
meet or there were several parents who
were invited not to return well there's
that but actually okay first I think
you that that well there's that but I
think you all you all did do something
really helpful last legislative session
which was you passed
hp38 and what that as you recall did was
it made it so that for parents and
people with disabilities for whom it's
not reasonably practicable for them to
attend meetings in person that it allows
them to participate remotely and that's
hugely helpful in terms of recruitment
because as you know you know parents
have to take you can't be in two places
at the same time it's difficult for
parents to attend meetings in the AV
you know it's we don't have a lot of
public
transportation child care so I think you
know you should be commended for that
step because that is going to make
recruitment a lot easier it's going to
make participation a lot easier La at
last night's meeting this the um
advisory committee did vote to allow
remote participation under HB 308 for
parents for you know for not just
parents but anyone for whom it's not
reasonably practicable for them to
attend in person we're still we still
have some technological glitches um
which are being worked out um because we
need to make sure the technology the
Wi-Fi where we were meeting was terrible
last night but we're but that's being
addressed and so that is a huge thing
that you all did that should really help
tremendously thank
you represent
cascaden uh thank
you um so it's if there is the
opportunity to bring in a specialist
because children with dis disabilities
as you know those Specialists could vary
so
wide but as long as you have that
specialist when you need it then I don't
see why we need to have a health care
provider that's one thing the other
thing is you just mentioned parents can
now zoom into the committee
meeting which now gives you the
opportunity I don't know where the
committee meets but it gives you the
opportunity to have representation of
parents from every County or every
region um so I think that's a plus as
well so that's pretty much it that's
where I stand thank you we use technical
support and put them on people on
committees often I sat
in uh two meetings this week already
where we had uh for example Steve
applebe uh sitting in who's director of
higher ed At Doe who sat in at the
teacher shortage committee we have tal
Hub who sat in at and
participated uh in the dissolution of
charter school or dissolution of charter
schools yesterday um so it's possible
put a technical support person but I I
kind of agree that your technical
support is going to vary whether it's a
pediatrician or it's somebody's dealing
with a severe Orthopedic issue of some
kind so it it's it's going to vary yeah
and and I think it really depends on you
know what issues people on the committee
become aware of
so we there may not be an orthopedic
issue right or there may be a real you
know we may become aware of students
with a certain type of disability having
struggling more to get have their needs
met than others and at that point it
might be really helpful to bring someone
in who has the technical expertise that
would really benefit the sax ability to
give appropriate rep um recommendations
my son sees a complex care physan
because because he's complex um and she
sees children and adults with a variety
of disabilities often multiple
disabilities um most significant but she
doesn't see children who have learning
disabilities as a primary category or
reading disabil just reading
disabilities or emotional disabilities
so even having someone like that you're
gaps right that's for Jack Bel was very
good because he was the
dyslexia
reading
superlative um any other questions from
the committee thank you very much
representa
kab good morning good morning thank you
for having me up um do you have a copy
of uh Glenn rep cordell's uh proposal he
said that he was going to have it um
available yes we we do okay um because I
want to kind of comment on on that a bit
so I was appointed to se this winter and
I've been to I believe six of their
meetings now and I also want to point
out that while I am appointed as a House
member I do also have two children in
elementary school that are on IEP so I
could also qualify as a parent member
and just saying that in the sense that
my heart's in it for for the kids um and
the committee is truly made up of some
wonderful people who are volunteering
their time and and giving their best um
and I think it's important to say that
of course everybody wants to be on the
committee and nobody's going to say sure
take my seat because it's a volunteer
thing so if they didn't want to be on it
they wouldn't be on it they would have
just resigned um but I do think it's
important that
we look at it from a lens of is the
committee actually meeting its current
purpose right now and if I'm going to be
honest the answer is no um in all of the
meetings that I've gone to they've been
focused on how the committee should run
itself and not talking anything about
children at all and that was the same
theme in last night's meeting as well
which I'm sure babon will agree with um
it's been talking there was two meetings
talking about a member that was on the
committee if she should be able to get
um an accommodation for her disability
in in terms of participating on with the
group there is a meeting that um
centered around 91a issues um there were
there was a several meetings and emails
that went back and forth basically
um asking the doe to provide a minute
taker rather than just appoint somebody
on the committee itself to be a clerk
and and of course to fund the minute
taker as well um and so there hasn't
been an annual report that's been
finalized and posted since the 2018 2019
season and I I do want to go back and
say that while the majority has not been
met by parents in a long time the last
report that I could find that it was was
was back in 2014 when uh Miss Dunham was
chair and I will say during that time a
lot of wonderful things were
accomplished there was Memo after memo
commenting on different policy changes
legislative changes and they even
organized a Statewide advocacy day
regarding special education so I think
the committee absolutely can function
but is it functioning now no and I think
we need to do something to try and help
fix that so I I think that's where rep
cordelli was coming from with with his
Amendment and striking some further
people off of off of the group that were
not federally required um and regarding
the the pediatrician piece I think the
important thing to note is that while
Specialists each specialize in one
little niche pediatricians see see
children for every single that may have
any
disability always and so they're the the
the gatekeeper the one that's that's
giving out out um referrals to different
Specialists let's say a child like is
having is is speech delayed or needs PT
OT Ortho any of these reasons they're
going to be referring the child out and
a lot of times an issue is then
discovered and the parents are going to
the pediatrician well what do we do the
pediatricians are the ones that that
should be guiding them and telling them
well if your child's over three you can
go and get an evaluation and maybe they
qualify for special education because a
lot of parents don't know that the other
thing is part of an IEP is asking
certain pieces if there's medical
necessity to them and if there is you
often have a pediatrician that's writing
a note that this device is medically
required for this child and we don't we
have that missing piece and I think why
it's important to have it is if that
person was on the committee and getting
this feedback and hearing things they
could go back um even to the New
Hampshire
uh Association of of Pediatricians and
say hey like there's this missing piece
would you mind sending a memo out to let
other providers know XYZ and so I think
that part would be a hugely helpful and
I don't think it should be a certain
specialized provider because then I
think you're getting into that niche of
only a
certain uh subset of disabilities and I
do kind of agree I do agree very much so
with what uh attorney Rosenberg said
that if you're going to ask somebody to
be on a committee especially one
that's not been functioning very well
like this one it's pretty frustrating to
go on a committee but then not be able
to have your voice because I think the
other pieces is that you know why
participate if you
can't kind of have a full voice on it so
that's kind of their perspective that
I'm coming in and I you know I've heard
from several that sit up now and I'm not
going to point at anybody in particular
but that they've experienc similar
issues and so this isn't a new issue um
with sack it's been an issue for for
several years and I I do think there was
many years ago that it was working and
right now it's not and it hasn't been
for a while so that's kind of where I
was coming from thank you um
representative
leus so do you see having the
pediatrician on there more as a um
gathering information like for
pediatricians in general to go from the
committee back to the community more
that than the pediatrician giving input
to the community to the committee yes
exactly and that's why I think important
for them to sit on there because I don't
I think we're missing that kind of Med
toed link where if there are problems
the pediatricians just aren't hearing
about them and you know we've never I
mean the again like I can't I think that
a lot of the members do want to make
changes because many of them have come
out personally to testify for bills but
as a group we haven't necessarily put
forth even one initiative so I think it
would be unfair to say we haven't called
in a pediatrician I mean we haven't but
we also haven't done really any other
initiatives either that since I been on
it thank you represent dry thank you Mr
chairman thank you for coming in uh this
um representative cordell's uh proposal
here do you feel like that trims this
down enough and does adding a clerk is
something that you have to choose along
with a chairperson solve the problem of
logistics thank you for the question so
I do believe that adding the clerk piece
in would also we do elect a chair and
that's been statutory I think if a clerk
were also to be elected that would
remove the piece that was took uh quite
a bit
of um heated debate um over the course
of several meetings and many emails I do
think that that would solve that problem
and it would be a fiscally responsible
way of doing it because somebody's
already there um and could just take the
me meeting minutes for free just like
follow uh I thought this was
it was it's one on your
Des so just to clarify it doesn't have
his name on it this was just handed out
to me so but is that what we're
referring to is yes is this what we're
referring to yes okay and that does also
pieces when you introduced
representative the bill uh initially as
introduced it spoke to several things
one eliminate one of the correctional
facility people and two dealing with one
local Health provider period it didn't
mention anything about clerks it didn't
mention anything about some of the
discussed pedi pediatrician in fact
looking at pediatricians right now I'm
reading an article in the Wall Street
Journal just the other day there's only
one Pediatric Hospital that has a
pediatric department up north and that's
Dartmouth Hitchcock all the others do
not and so it's a rare bird that we're
trying to look for here uh but but going
back to this so that was your initial
bill as introduced approved by the
council not approved no it was I did
have some members ask me to put it in it
was prior to me being on there and
that's where um when some of these other
suggestions were made I did agree with
after sitting on the committee myself
and I do want to say um the reason that
word healthcare provider was put on
there before was in case it wasn't
necessarily an MD but it it was a an NP
or something and there are actually
several pediatricians that I'm
personally aware of that would be
honored to sit on the committee so um I
I don't think that it would be a
difficult position to fill and the
second question then I'll go over to you
represent pent um representer cordelli
has a number of changes within this
right here have those were those
discussed at all with the organization
last night no the zoom was not um
working properly at all so I wasn't able
to communicate with the group um R bbon
um kind of did a bit of a as you know
suggested that it was going to be talked
about and there was a a poll kind of
done on the original pieces of it but I
I do want to say
that sometimes when you're too close to
an issue it's easy to say I don't want
these changes but it doesn't mean that
that's actually what's in the best
interest because is it functioning right
now no
and I think we've got to make some
changes so I you know we have to make
changes that are in the best interest of
the the kids receiving special ed
services and not based on our
personal um likes necessarily and I I
also want to say if you guys decided
that there should only be one rep on
there I would I'd be willing to give up
my seat because I feel that strongly
that this committee could do wonderful
things
and I hope that it can get back to the
spot where it will thank you
representative pel thank you I just
wanted to go back to the healthc care
provider comment and representative
Tanner had an amendment that was trying
to um require a more specialized
individual and I told you I would follow
up with our own local pediatrician and I
did and he thought that almost any
pediatrician would fit this bill because
they do deal with special needs children
on a regular basis so I just want to let
you know that I had followed up and done
my homework thank
you yes represent Allison but
representative Cordell is not here to to
speak to his Amendment but uh two of the
issues that jump out at me uh on the
amendment and then I'm the printing
they're in the middle of a page but it
takes one representative the disability
rights Center off the committee and one
representative of the parent information
center off the committee I would like to
know the rationale for uh his
recommendation but obviously he can't
speak because he's not here yeah so I
think part of the rationale was is that
again we don't have a majority of
parents and those are not required under
federal law those those pieces so if
those pieces were removed we would have
more we would have a higher percentage
of a parent majority we again we haven't
met it since in in nine years at this
point when I went back and looked
through reports and we are we are
federally mandated to meet it and we
haven't and there have been posts in
groups and I think people have come in
you know tried out the committee and
seen that it's dysfunctional and not
returned that's cuz we follow up yes
um I guess then and I understand the
issue of we all do of 50% 51% parents on
here and so there's going to be some
juggling which is going on here uh it
would seem to me though that you have to
keep in mind where people are coming
from from organizations and what they
bring to the the committee and the fact
is if you then got to find two more
parents then you weigh that sort of
thing I guess I'm I'm just I I'm
surprised at that those two
organizations Representatives have been
taken off that would be taken off the
committee under the amendment
understanding full well that got to find
some more parents I I I do understand
that and I and I mean I I personally
very much so like and respect the
representatives from those and I you
know great people but I think at the
same time for the last nine years we've
been trying to they've been trying to
recruit more parents and haven't been
able to meet that so to just say recruit
more parents it's not working um we
haven't been able to do that so how are
we going to actually be able to comply
with the federal law somebody has to
come off and it's it's going to have to
be pieces that are not federally
required and I I would say like yes
somebody can come in and give
presentations and whatnot still it's not
that nobody would be able to participate
even and and still get that
same input thank you yes representative
Damon so I'm wondering if you could
offer some clarification I'm not sure it
was you who said it but someone in the
hearing this morning or the discussion
this morning that if you're a parent on
the committee but you're on the
committee filling a different role then
you don't count as a parent to meet the
51% Quorum do I have that
parent
so I think if you're coming from the
perspective of I'm here as a parent with
a child with a disability um I don't
think you can necessarily just say that
the other person is a parent because the
the Mandate is that they would be a
parent of a child with a disability not
parent I think I interpreted the pro
sorry go ahead I think I interpreted the
prior comment to mean that they were a
parent of a child with a
disability thank you so is that federal
law that is saying folks who are on
appointed
for a role that is a non-parent role
it's um I think the way that it's worded
says something like the majority of the
members shall
be either parents of children with uh
disability or they should
themselves I think I think what we'll do
is because I I had had a talk with folks
upstairs in research earlier Jen's not
here today she's out of state at a
conference Jennifer 4 but I think this
is an issue we need to get an answer to
Is this specifically stated in federal
law or state law that you can't be here
as both um I think I think that's very
important I'm here because I'm a
grandparent and I could have gotten off
this position a long time ago but I have
a very vested interest in ensuring that
those children are going to get the best
op opportunity for an education as
possible and I feel this is my little
way of helping so I can serve as both
and I often times tell you about the the
youngster the other day that was my
little Kindergarten kid was in the
thinking chair you remember that and and
so you know you had to think he made a
wrong choice so um I I think it's
important so we will get a specific
answer in that
one okay yes there we go hello
Rebecca welcome
Rebecca is from doe yes director of
Special Education Service I'm Rebecca
fad I'm the state director of special
education so there is no rule federally
or state that says that you can't um
have a member as Caitlyn is a member who
is also considered a parent in other
states they do count parents towards
that they they would count Caitlyn
towards that number as for an example
they would say that yes you are a
representative but you're also a parent
and we count you towards the the parent
parent number in New Hampshire that is
not in our statute and it has not
previously been done um but there are
other states that do count those parents
towards that um parent
number very interesting representative
McDonald thank you Mr chair and thank
you all for um speaking today if parents
were counted if members such as
representative cutab who qualifies as
both were counted also as parents do you
know if the Quorum would have been met
previously I would have to clarify which
ones um would qualify I as a parent um
Caitlyn is open and says that she has a
child with a disability um I would have
to check with all the other members and
see if they have children with
disabilities that would that would um
make them count okay thank you y do say
parent with disabilities or just plain
parent parent of a child disability just
parent or parent of a child with a
disability of a child
with further questions of doe yes or rep
yes represent Ford thank you Mr
chair is there any provision
for thank you is there any provision for
support of people who volunteer as a
parent with a child so that they can
participate supported by someone to care
for the child while they're doing the
committee
part there is nothing um that is in the
provision of the law that says that that
would be provided to them um and that's
not something that has been previous
done you have a lot more experience than
most everyone in the room so I'm going
to ask you is it likely that that would
be a beneficial thing to provide as a
resource um potentially it it depends on
the children of the individuals that are
in here um it depends on their medical
condition um I know many of the parents
have children who are medically fragile
so to put several children in one space
may not be the best choice so there's a
lot of factors that um would play into
that I I I think it would help but would
it be feasible is is more the I'm not
thinking of bringing him all into one
room for
sure I'm thinking of offsite yeah uh but
that however it would be worked by the
people who know how to do these things
and I'm not one of them um but it it
just the idea occurred to me that if I
were such a parent I might be really
frightened the idea of leaving my child
in some unspecified care or whatever
that if that could be arranged then I
might feel Freer to contribute my
experience expertise whatever uh yeah to
the
discussion um there is remote
participation allowed it was previously
allowed for there the majority had to be
in person and then you could have other
members participating remotely so there
were parents who for child care reasons
uh did participate remotely and now
uh with the law that uh changed and was
in effect I believe two days ago only
onethird have to be in person and if the
others needed to be home for childcare
reasons they could participate remotely
on Zoom yeah so I think that kind of
does solve a little bit of that problem
I think we've all had a long-term lesson
in Zoom that we would rather not have
been afflict inflicted upon us but uh
perhaps some of us came out with a more
positive experience than others but I've
had all of those I want to have and uh
so that said uh yes and thank you thank
you are there any other questions yes
represent Damon then
caner go
ahead separately from the parts we've
been discussing in representative
cordell's
proposal the two members of the house
and the reduced to one member of the
Senate he's removed that they be members
of Education committee
I would Express a preference for one of
the two members of the house to be a
member of Education
committee I think we need the liais on
the communication back and forth um and
that that would be helpful to have
represent
Tanner I just um I was looking at that
first line of the group of parents and
it uh it says individuals with
disabilities or parents of children with
disabilities appointed by the governor
um and so my question is it it could
could be just a person with uh
disabilities not necessarily a
parent If there really dision it could
be a child of a um which is under the
age of 26 is how it's defined so it
could be a child with a disability um as
defined by the law yes well but even you
have you have another listing of a a CH
of child with disabilities but this is
in um you know the first line where it
says individuals with disabilities or
parents of children with disabilities
appointed by the governor so I'm I'm
just wondering if if an individual with
disabilities not necessarily a parent at
that point would count for the Quorum
yes yes and the other thing is is there
an
issue with the appointment by the
governor is that anything that's holding
up for people coming on no is not okay
pen thank you I have a question for you
Mr chair and then I have a followup can
you repeat how many um pieces of
legislation we have coming across our
desk 09 109 just from the house side
that is correct and follow it we'll have
more I would suggest
that most a lot of most a good portion
of that legislation did not come from
members of our committee and that there
would be that there must be a
significant number of members of the
house who are very interested and have a
vested interest in education including
special needs so I am pretty sure the
speaker could find one member of the
House outside of the education committee
who would be more than
happy representative cab as an as a
perfect example to serve on this
committee so I don't see why it would
have to be somebody from the education
committee that's just further further
discussion um so from the Department
does the department see the strikeouts
that representative cordelli has as
being uh uh bettering the that Council
or going the opposite direction One
represent of a disability rights Center
one represent of a parent information
center those would be
eliminated so we wouldn't take a stand
on whether it would make it better or
worse um I think that it makes it
closely more closely aligned to the
federal language um and it also takes
into that consideration that we have not
been able to get that 51% for parents
okay so I understand the reasoning
behind it I don't know if it would be
better or worse or I would not want to
speak to that so I think it just would
fed more align it with the federal
language
further yes rson Cel so overall and I
don't know if there's a question in here
but I just have to make a comment just
hearing all of this it becomes quite
obvious the dysfunctionality of this
committee and um it's hard for me to
even understand what it does uh we're
talking all about all these different
people and different categories and
parents but I just wanted to get out
there that I agree that this idea that
in a sense you could uh double dip and
reach this Quorum of the parents being
51% by having people who you know
hypothetically it seems to me that one
of the things that makes it
dysfunctional and unwieldy is the number
of people on the committee
hypothetically let's just say you could
find parents with children with
disabilities in every single one of
these categories I'm not saying you can
and you shouldn't leave out people who
might be qualified otherwise but um to
to have a concerted effort to do that I
think is
important I just want to make a comment
I guess there's no question in that but
but I think it's a very important issue
this idea of is it okay for this sort of
double dipping to meet the
requirements represent leus if it's a is
it a question for I know what I was
going to say is when we're done here can
we have these two ladies come back up
sure we'll take all the technical
support we can get
here so you don't have a question
anybody else have a question
for thank you very much there is also a
parent um from the committee here as
well so if if we're letting people speak
just to be fair I just wanted to point
much Karen and Bonnie you willing to
forth
you so now that we've been discussing as
somebody referred to it as double
dipping and you know a number presumably
a number of the people on the committee
do you think that if we just added in
that it could count you know they could
count for both that that would solve the
numerical issues you're
having it would certainly
help um I know of several people um the
right now the representative from parent
information center is a parent um at
least one of the parent with a child of
a child with a disability um at least
one of the um Educators or
administrators I believe has been a
surrogate parent um may still I believe
still is but I'm not positive and a
surrogate parent is in the definition of
a parent um an educational surrogate
parent so I don't know if it would
completely solve it because I don't have
all of the numbers in my head that quite
a few people have been appointed and the
governor didn't appoint anybody for two
years and so that it was
pretty difficult for a while we only had
one member who was
actively um eligible because everybody
else's term had
expired yeah I I think I I think we
would need more information enough if
that solves the issue but I think it I
think the committee really ought to
consider how really Monumental the
change in the law is and and the you
know that will allow more remote
participation the last couple of years I
I mean I was on this SEC it was very
difficult because we could not achieve a
quorum and because of that we could not
get we could not further the mission of
the sack or or really because we just
couldn't do anything because we could
not achieve 51% in person and
participation of our
members and um so you know I I think you
know that made the organization not able
to function I was on this sack I've been
on it for Bonnie probably knows she's an
incredible historian at least 10 years
you have since dick left right and and
there were many years when our
subcommittees met where we made
recommendations on we spent a lot of
time um on a subcommittee on the rules
for the education of children and youth
with disabilities and came up with a
recommendation for kind of a changes in
our rules that um was a really a
collaborative um effort that the entire
that there was a subcommittee and then
the entire um committee voted on and
these had to do with preserving rights
for parents to be active participants in
decisions involving their children so it
retained rights for parents to get
information like for example um reports
that were done on evaluations 3 days
before a meeting so that they but have
an opportunity to review them to things
like that to be able at certain notices
and retaining time frames for decisions
to be made and for parents to be
notified in meetings so I think this and
that was really a a big effort that the
sack undertook and completed and as a
result I think our rules are in pretty
good shape when it comes to providing
opportunities for parents to be equal
participants in decisions that involve
their children's education so I
acknowledge that the the past couple
years pandemic wre Havoc with a lot of
work that our committee attempted to
accomplish it made wreaked havoc on
public education right but hopefully
we're coming out from the other end of
that we now have you know more support
for some remote participation which
should help us to recruit and retain um
parents others with disabilities who
have a more challenging time
participating in meetings in person we
have new leadership that just started
yesterday um and we had a really
productive meeting we were and I think
that we're on a good path um but the you
know the the co really wreaked havoc
with a lot of Nationwide New Hampshire
wide and this committee really suffered
as a result but I don't I think that
it's not really about the numbers so
much we need to make our parent majority
it really has to do with making sure
that we can meet our Quorum that we can
collaborate and get our job done and I
think we can do that now that we've um
returned to whatever normal is
but can can I add an explanation of why
parent information center and
disabilities rights Center were added
and kept when Senator Styles reviewed
that committee and it was
because in talking about the unmet needs
of children with disabilities no one
ever calls pick or DRC when their needs
are being met we only hear about the
unmet needs of parents of children with
disabilities all disabilities throughout
the state birth to 26 the entire range
of Ages and disabilities and Geographic
um ranges of the of the state um and so
we're able to bring that perspective of
what we are hearing as unmet needs to
the committee as well I mean really
about a quarter of the inquiries to our
office involve education for children
with disabilities it's a 100% 100% of
yours
obviously other questions here yes
represent Cornell so you would see that
position that should remain as part of
the committee not be taken out yes both
of them or one of both both should
remain in do different things
okay represent
Tanner and kind of a followup with uh
representative Cornell's um thoughts as
you look through this
recommendation um H and and you said I
think you said that you would like to
see you know that the Quorum be is an
issue so if we go down through and I
don't know if you have a copy of the you
don't have a copy of the things but but
whether we could go down through and see
if um you could point out which ones
that you think should be I mean I don't
think the quarum is an issue anymore we
had an in-person quarum at our meeting
last night and um without even having to
you know we had a few people
participating remotely but most people
were in person
and I think that with the change in the
law that we're not going to have the
quarm isn't going to be as much of an
issue I think what we what we really
need um going forward is to try to
address the issue of having enough
parent represent parents of students
with disabilities people with
disabilities and students with
disabilities on the committee I think
that the change in the law will help
that because it will allow people
geographically and with other kinds of
challenges to participate so it's at
this point I think
it's I mean never say like it's perfect
but I think the quarum issue is not so
much of a problem now we're not in the
midst of a pandemic that is requiring
people to stay home and we know that
people can participate remotely it's
more that the issue really is the 51%
issue and I think that the change in the
law is going to help us to recruit
parents and others just follow up on
that so so let me just um so one of the
issues was to add a health care person
and I noticed on this it said one local
health care provider um are you in favor
of that or not not I'm not because why
create a you know a parent participation
issue where we don't need to and I think
that this committee has been able to
secure outside Consultants when needed
in the time I've been there we've had
lots of outside people come in and
present to our committee on issues that
the committee is interested in examining
and and um if if we had an amendment
about uh allowing people to count as
both uh would that help you
out I I think it would be helpful I
don't know I can't speak for the
committee but it would address the
numbers issue and recognize that people
can be both state employees for example
but also parents of students with
disabilities and see through that lens
as well because I think the idea is to
make sure that the views of parents and
students with disabilities who are
benefiting from the services or
navigating the education process are
represented on the committee so I don't
know that because you wear more than one
hat that would preclude you from being
able to view through that lens and and
do you um also I think you did before
say uh it wasn't a big deal to go from
two senators down to one
as long as I've been on the committee
which like I said Bonnie knows longer
than me I think I remember Senator Khan
being probably the last senator who was
actively involved and appointed I don't
know that anyone's been appointed since
Senator Khan
and okay so going down to one Senator is
not gonna change anything I just wanted
to get I wanted to get clear what
changes you were advocating for we're
very fortunate to get one Senator on any
kind of commit I look the keep shortage
committee and we have one showing up and
that happens to be you know the chair of
Senate Ed who really has a
responsibility to be there uh so but I I
can't remember when I was on there of
course why a lot of reps didn't go that
time is you were scheduling on Thursday
afternoon at 4:00 and we were always in
session right and so we just couldn't
escape to drive across town to get there
so but uh senators I I don't think
they'd mind if we turned it down put it
back to one I think they'd jump up and
say thank
you oh Senator Styles came oh Nancy came
sure yes she did and she was very active
in that and but she was also you know a
chair of the committee of the education
committee right so there
there's so taking a straw vote here with
people right here how many folks you
know this just straw vote you can change
your mind later at this time how many
people are thinking that we ought to go
from two to one
Senator see there's where we are so I
don't think there needs to be any more
discussion on that point um now how many
people feel that we should have uh two
members continue from the from the house
to continue two members I do in one one
education and I I will support that well
and that that was going to be my next
question should we be eradicating
education committee or should we just
leave leave it there I the way it is I
think you need to leave two members of
the Senate education two members of the
House Education committee or rework it
so at least one member from the house is
from the education committee and the
senator can be from any
committee valer you have hand yeah is it
possible to write a member of the house
but a preference for the education
committee I think we'd be wise to
produce something if we're going to
still have two
members one two members in the house of
which one must be from the education
committee that's the way most language
is written how many people would be up
for that latter part where of which one
must be from the education committee two
members of which one so we have a
majority there okay so we've gotten a
couple things some resolve there there's
another area where we have one local
education official and I always have a
question because local is in this bill
several places what is the definition of
local wondered that
too and and so um you know are we
looking for an administrator an
education education administrator um um
and is that the same thing
representative cascaden is your
education director in the school
district I don't think
so no it seems like the term
was I I think of it as an Lea you know
local educational administrator who can
sign off get of in some meetings but
never heard it local educational
official yeah for an administrator I
mean you're already having
um a specialed
teacher
um but it wouldn't hurt to instead of
two teachers having a special ed teacher
and a special ed administrator see we
also have other areas where we've added
in one local Health
provider
okay Rebecca welcome
back so the
um right so the administrator um is
typically a special education
administrator or a special ed director
that's who we've typically put on right
now there's currently a special
education director who fulfills that
role does that answer the question and
that comes from Jane's Organization no
it does not that's an old the language
about it coming from NASA is old
language it is just somebody that um
expresses interest we usually put it out
to the field and say we're looking for
somebody um and then it goes through the
commissioner and the governor's office
person so where where are we on as a
group right here on one local education
official who shall be an administrator
appointed by the governor two
administrators represent Amon thank you
could one or all of you weigh in on on
the proposal here that position is
omitted is it do do you want there to be
this local special ed director or other
administrator included you need
administrators idea is plural If you
eliminate that you have one
administrator so on here line
f is one and is crossed talk you're also
referring to another line idba says
administrat of programs for children
with disabilities so there and then line
um L is one administrator for special
education public special education
program so there's one that is a local
education official and then one that's a
administrative that's how we meet the
follow I think that it's not what we
want it's what the Federal Law requires
so the Federal Law requires more than
one so we
can't um I lost my place here sorry we
can't remove line F and be in compliance
with federal law because we'd only have
one administrator and we're supposed to
have more than one right same with the
teachers it's plural you can't eliminate
one
ah
so may I yes go ahead so then you just
referenced line G where the proposal is
to reduce two to one and that would make
it not compliant with federal law right
thank
you represent parel yeah I just want to
make one point um
for parents with typical healthy
children it can be really challenging to
come to to attend a meeting and Conquer
and find child care so that would be
addressing representative Ford's comment
and I know Zoom is this new wonderful
technology that we've all discovered but
um I just want you to keep in mind
that even with typical healthy children
a parent who might be trying to attend a
zoom meeting can have you don't know
what's going to happen behind you while
you're trying to be on that Zoom meeting
and trying to maybe watch your children
and pay attention while you're on the
zoom meeting will be challenging so I
can't even imagine um parents of special
needs children who have even more issues
that might pop up would also find even
Zoom meetings difficult to attend so I
just want to make that point that it
might still be just as challenging
reaching that per parental
Quorum we haven't really recruited
parent information center and DRC have
typically put the word out looking for
parents and I don't know about DRC but
parent information center hasn't done
that in the past few years because there
hasn't been a point to doing it since
they couldn't they couldn't come in
person when during the the pandemic and
so that can that can happen again which
would increase the numbers certainly it
always has yeah I mean you make a really
good point it is challenging I mean one
thing that might be considered I think
it was representative Ford who talked
about like a child care subsidy as
something that would really support um
parents ability to attend um and and you
know I think I think I'm where I'm where
you are representative for it it's like
Zoom like you know I mean I think you
almost use the term Affliction it is
something that I mean it is a really
great tool it is going to be really
helpful I think for parents who with or
without child care who are wanting to
participate but live in Berlin and just
aren't going to be able to do it to be
so we I think it will help us with
geographical diversity and recruiting
but we could consider further supports
for parents in terms of um some kind of
Child Care Subsidy I think in the past
parents I don't know if this is still
happening um Rebecca fet would know but
parents were at least given some
Transportation reimbursement I don't
know if that's still being made
available to parents but if there are
ways that this committee could um
recommend supports for to enable and
facilitate parent representation that be
okay I want to just walk through a few
other points here that we might want to
consider are we all in favor of asking
Rebecca to find those states that allow
a person to be there in two capacities
one as a parent and Rebecca could you
try to find that for us I don't have Jen
right here she won't be back for another
week so if you could find that out maybe
direct us a little bit or even craft
something yourself to to enable that to
occur I think that might get us over one
of our hurdles here thank
you all right so obviously we're not
going to get you know something done
here today and we have a number of bills
but I think we've really delved into
this so we can come up with something
are there any other critical points in
this bill
that we we should be looking at and
thinking of of mending language we
didn't really really resolve the issue
of one local care provider um maybe we
should take a straw vote on that whether
or how we should do that you know
there's technical support available
there's also right here and your your
language that you have near Bill Linda
represented Tanner is much more specific
than that which we see coming forward in
147 um you're talking about you know
have
uh practiced in these particular areas
are you getting too narrow it's going to
be difficult to find the Beast well we
also talked about maybe opening it up um
when that Amendment came through for
phys Physicians assistance uh that may
be working with children as well um so I
yes I I definitely think that that bill
was too narrow and but I'd also like to
just go down on the other letters um
well can we just stick to this one for a
second do we want to see something in
there referencing Health a new position
with a health provider of some sort ref
I think they said they felt comfortable
with not having theye it's up to us
though rewrite rewrite statute but we
rely on the people on the committee
absolutely absolutely but you know
I we're goingon to have to resolve that
one way or the other representative
casad I see more value in keeping that
um DRC and the parent information center
than do a healthare provider okay repres
leus um it seems that the health care
provider is there for information going
the other way if they need information
on a spec of a specific technical they
can ask that person to come in but the
health provider was to get the
information from this committee out
to pediatricians and the general
Community having to do with health and I
can see that that would be a useful
thing because I don't see another way
another means of communication like we
want to keep somebody from the Ed
committee on this so that they can come
back and talk to us so I can see having
a and it just the amendment says health
care provider so that would include your
nurse practitioner whatever it's more
generic um so that they can see what the
issues are and bring them back to their
community
being yes represent cordal I see it as
an advantage also to have a health care
provider right on this uh committee um
what we've been talking about this whole
time is how dysfunctional this committee
is and how it doesn't work so maybe this
is one of the problems you say you can
call in experts and that seems to be
complicated um if you had someone right
on board who was familiar with uh
Healthcare in some way whether whether
it be a pediatrician or you could open
it up you know a physician's assistant
someone who would have some expertise in
that area would
bring that to the committee itself I
think that would be a
plus repres
for I'd just like to bring us all back
to the real world the people you're
talking about are not people who like
meeting and committees they have a job
they have so many hours to do it they
build by the hour
they move the patients through as
expeditiously as they can and they don't
have time in their professional lives to
sit on a committee that wants to talk
the issue to death and we're all guilty
of
that we've sat in those committees we
participated we know who we are but they
don't have time for that they want to
see a problem they want to diagnose it
and they want you to do it and if really
it's up to us to disseminate we can
disseminate they just have to tell us
what to
disseminate we can hire them to do that
by the hour it'll be a lot cheaper and
they'll be more willing to
work and then we handle dis semination
that's my two
sets Okay
so take a a straw pull on this one right
here this this health provider language
could could they it does the person that
comes in from Health and Human
Services uh I'm talking about line H one
representative Department of Health
involved in financing or delivery of
special education or related services to
children with disabilities would that
person have a line with uh health
providers that might be able to make a
recommendation or get the technical
support for you from Bonnie
orhs I mean that's not what their role
is if they if I mean if they might be a
good contact if we needed to to talk to
someone from like special medical
services for example which would be a
state agency Person Medical person who
could come in um they might be able to
facilitate that but it's not really
they're not a provider
Rebecca the representative for DHHS that
fulfills that role um works with the
residential facilities that we approve
as private providers of programs y thank
you okay so straw vot do we need to have
a health provider on the
committee put your hands up if you say
one
negative other words it's putting
language
in
vo to strike out the need for one Health
provider as a member of the committee
not that you wouldn't have somebody
there that's
invited but as a member put your hand up
if you're against that when one two
three four five
six to not have a a voting member right
here that you got the line that's to
bill yes yes so raise your hand if you
want if that's how you see
want to delete to
delete yeah I can go either way too
however I think we can do it through a
different way one one two three four
five six seven
eight so there is a majority here saying
that but that's not going to you know
we'll have to wait and see so that's
that question's still up in the
air all righty so is there anything else
we need to do at this point in time what
we do need to do is we need to get a
committee Amendment put together
here um and we've addressed several
items here and there's we need to have
one more meeting here and we'll bring
some draft Amendment language in and
then when we have everybody here this
will be before the November meeting so
we're gonna have to have one more on
this
Brill so um yes can we do a on not
deler
oh yeah I that that would be uh
I I and J yeah it's not on my sheet here
of okay
opposed I I think I think we're going to
leave it now that's the way so there
there are several things we've been able
to straw boo figure out get some common
ground we're getting there so we well
we're we're getting there and and that
that's what we want to do so we will
come back with some draft language is
there anybody would like to help craft
this draft Linda I know you've got your
hand
up and represent Bon you want help too
so why why don't you guys try to put
some G put something together here with
the the draft that we've discussed and
Esto says yes and and then we'll capture
the other
stuff the what the
corrections well because that's whoops
correction officers yeah let's have a
straw vote on that whether we keep both
Corrections folks in in so leave it as
it is now in law how many would support
leaving it as it is in law right now the
corrections the corrections are
so got State and the local County
keep
two keeping two keeping the different
levels so one two 3 four
five six S 8 nine 10 yeah we'll keep
that in we'll keep that in because we're
right at that point where we can you
know muster it won't kill the
Bill thank you so with that we're going
to take a short break and then we're
going to hop into I know there's been
some people in here wanting to deal with
uh dissolution of CH Charter School
building 8 yeah that's where we'll we'll
go next take about five minutes Shake it
bit so we'll set up a time here in
I
okay I'd like to go ahead and get into
uh
354 as everybody Might Recall 354 is
relative to Charter Public School
eligibility for State Building state
School building
Aid and so with that we start looking at
19815 in
statute and uh try to meld in the
charter school building a program into
that
legislation uh I'll remind folks that
there's we did some passage of the
school building aid process uh last year
uh Amy W us the title the number of the
bill can you recall that we just passed
the application
process 452 that's it was 452 which
changed statue around
significantly and with that it's now
impacting bills that we have
retained and and and so and there's
other bills out there now looking at the
whole formula which and I've mentioned
it before that one will be coming in
through the
Senate so I have put together an
amendment
here based upon those changes which we
had made by
452 and with the attorney looking at
trying to craft around that trying to
meld it into current language in what is
law right
now and it was shared
yesterday with the charter school
disillusion committee that's a committee
that looks at okay what what happens
when a charter school goes out of
business whether it be voluntarily or
involuntarily it goes out what happens
for example with the liabilities what
happens with the building if its own
what happens to Student Records where
are they sent who handle soci Student
Records is it the resident District or
is it Department of
Education um and we've had that issue
come to us several times and and it's a
real concern so what this amendment does
and I I will show you just read through
some of the changes here and there's
already a few areas where it has to be
tweaked but going down on the first page
there does everybody have a copy Amy do
you have one was were there any extras
that came by there and there there's
lots of right here we have extras too
there what and
and here's here's a couple to take back
here okay in in Charter School law in
19815 what what this does is as the
original Bill did it says the local
student districts and Charter Public
Schools and Charter Public Schools has
been placed in all those locations
within law where we're speaking to
building Aid going out for public school
schools or
public on line 21 there's language there
which speaks to and and this is not
about a leased facility lease is handled
differently so we're just dealing with
those buildings for construction and
renovation that are
owned that are owned any Charter Public
School to be improved or constructed
using School building Aid shall be owned
by the Charter Public school and shall
be subject to a plan for disposition of
the Charter Public Schools assets
pursuant to RSA 194b colon
3 uh Roman 2 Z as approved by the State
Board of
Education going on down 25 uh line 25 a
Charter Public School that has elected
to participate in school building aid
grant program present through grade 12
for at least 20 years a school in that
District or
Charter Public School that disc
discontinues the use of f facilities
within 20 years shall be required to
repay the state 100% of the state Grant
received that is law right now for all
public schools and public acmy they have
to repay now there is an exception the
next sentence upon a showing of good
cause by School District or Charter
Public School the commissioner or the
department of education May wave this
penalty in whole or part on a caseby
casee
basis money and it burns
down um that's that's an exception you
may not have to repay because you have
nothing left and there's going to be a
need to find out get some emergency
money or placing the students in a
facility that's going to be functional
there's there's areas in law where the
commissioner needs that based on the
criteria set forth in our
19815 U through 19815 W so you got to go
back and look at the statutes to make
sure it's everything's built that way uh
state board shall approve okay uh going
down the amount of the grant to any
Charter Public School established in
accordance with this ra that RSA shall
be 30% of the eligible cost of
construction for Charter Public School
construction projects the amount the
annual Grant to any Charter Public
School shall be a sum equal to 5% of the
eligible Grant amount each year for 20
years upon approval of the application
for school building Aid grants by the
State Board of Education that came out
of the bill as
proposed not more than 10% of the
eligible Grant shall be dispersed until
the completion of the construction and
verification of the final cost of
construction have been made by the
Department of
Education going on I'm just pointing out
where the the the changes occur you can
find places where we inserted like on
page four again Charter Public School
Board of Trustees in the current
law and uh on page five the same
um
um it's just adding in Charter Public
School under some of that criteria
that's looked at and then on the last
page there are some significant changes
starting in line
16 uh the dissolution committee on
charter schools had some concerns about
the state maybe having liability for a
school that
closes that may be related not maybe
School building aid but other areas but
also for school building Aid we this
particular bill says the liability is
for that school only it goes on and says
and we also remember had the shity bond
in place Provisions for dissolution of
char Public Schools sign 17 uh Public
School including disposition of assets
or amendment of its program plan that's
in law in the event of a voluntary or
involuntary Charter Public School
dissolution and if the assets of the
school are insufficient to pay all
parties to whom the school owes
compensation the state shall not be held
liable so the state will not be held
liable for other assets which that uh
particular institution may have
incurred and the new paragraph in the
Bott
addressed an issue also the dissolution
charter school committee made a
recommendation on uh one in the event of
a voluntary or involuntary dissolution
of a Charter Public School remaining
Student Records maintained by the
Charter Public School shall be forwarded
to Department of Education if all
records maintained by the Charter Public
School have not been forwarded to the
residence and there has been since an
amendment brought forward by uh
represent cordelli who's also on that
committee I we met
yesterday uh there is concern about um
and I'll just read what he has because I
just have what he sent me right here um
he says we have tried this four year
okay it be uh the data shall not be
disclosed by the testing entity to any
other person organization entity or
government or any component thereof
other than the parent or Guardian the
department school or School District
shall not be used by the testing entity
for any other purpose except as provided
in RSA 193c colon
12 um so it's trying to make sure that
the records which are sent from the
Charter Public School don't go anywhere
else other than to the the resident
District or
doe so those are the changes that have
been suggested through another committee
so here we are and
legislation was put forth to try and
deal with some of this however it was
told to us we have a bill already in
committee dealing with much of this use
that bill as the bill to amend and
that's what we're having to do so that's
why it's in this bill right here at
354 open it up to
discussion yes represent leas
okay I have questions about two areas
one of them is the shity bond and I will
be honest I don't know enough about I
understand the purpose of shity bonds
but how much they actually
are
um and if they had a shity bond if they
could come up with a shity
bond could they not come up with the
money to pay for the building I'm not
sure if I would like explanation about
how that works and where that money
comes from and does somebody just
voluntarily put it up to be gotten back
hopefully or you know where are they
getting this money for this charity Bond
if they don't have money to pay for
building the school that's my question I
guess I'll give you an example what we
had to do up in my community we you know
we have Highway block money it comes
from the state it's for roads and
Bridges and the money that goes to the
Woodsville fire district which has their
own highway department has to pass
through the town from the state to town
to the district because they have their
by Statute their own uh highway
department for the roads in that fire
district the amount of the grant is
somewhere between $250,000 something
such that it's not a heck of a lot of
money but in terms of Highways but the
town said to the fire district you're
going to have to put up a bond to ensure
that you're using this money for the
stated
purpose and and the bond is a minimal
cost it's it's you're talking very
little dollars for it but it's kind of
crazy you have to do something like that
because it's going from one government
agency through one to another government
agency but the law said that they had to
do that so it's it's Amy do you have
anything else that you might be able to
add to shity bonds it's not for the
whole amount that you're you're getting
If you're receiving for example um
something like this and a and a a chart
of public school is you know maybe reing
upwards towards maximum maybe a couple
hundred, a year if it's spread over a
bunch of years their their building
needs are not going to be as big as the
$70 million project the state's going to
have to cough up for
concrete I'm just it it's says it will
be there and it'll be used for repayment
in compliance with paragraph 3 and so my
question you know if it's going to be
used for repayment how can it be really
small but if it's going to be large
enough to be used for repayment then how
are they going to be able to afford
it yeah and you know it's it's
um I think we ought to have somebody
come in that has that expertise to
explain that to us and and the amount of
the bond is not designated in this this
is just one of the Avenues which is
going down um some states have this
written in one where we took this from
was North
Carolina uh but they had several options
available and there were other options
but the dis the committee that Senator
Lang has said no I prefer that we just
have one AB bonding and Sally fellow was
on it as well
um and so this is an area that I'm not
going to try to explain it we'll we'll
have to get people in I'm just giving
you an idea this is what may come at us
and and we may have to end up this is
really draft right you're seeing right
there needs a lot of
work thank you and then my second
question is over
here
um 22 line 22 on page
two that they'll receive 5% the eligible
Grant each year for 20 years and there
was discussion of doing that for the
public schools and and we had decided
not to do that because it ends up making
the public school pay a lot more in
interest Etc so I'm wondering why we're
doing it for can you come on up for a
second
please you're you're the prime sponsor
of this bill and within the bill you had
the
5% you want Amy up there would you or I
would thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record I'm representative Moren Mooney
from the town of miramac yes the prime
sponsor of House Bill 354 and the prime
sponsor of the amendment that was an
exact duplicate of this language that
made it into and pass the house in house
bill to so this uh has wings that
section that you referred to I'm going
to ask a Amy Clark because I consulted
with her on my drafting of this bill on
that very section so Amy Clark from the
doe thank you yeah thank you so um
originally when this bill first came it
had the 80% upfront just like the public
schools did and there was a big concern
among the committee about dissolution
what if it goes Belly Up um and that's
what I call it Belly Up um and so the um
the compromise was to say well we won't
give 80% upfront because that's a lot of
money and if the school can um pay that
over 5% each year over 20 years like the
old uh Public School infrastruct uh like
the old school building Aid formula then
that would be a good compromise still
being eligible for building Aid yet
you're giving 5% each year it also for
me feels like I know that there is
concern for dissolution processes and
that probably it's a very valid concern
but having that language there really
protects the state's investment because
they're only giving a one 12th of that
every year for 20 years uh and it it
seemed to address that problem so that's
what we added in there thank you and I
know that the reason why we put less
depreciation as represented fellows is
also saying hey you know you depreciate
this facility or what Gatsby what uh
it's it's the federal stuff that over a
number of years the value of that dollar
is or the building is has gone down of
course so are you going to
be having to pay back the 5% 5% what you
put in over these years or or is it
going to be a depreciated amount of what
that value of that the money received
previously is now worth in in in regard
to the facility you know what I'm trying
to
say um I I'm not sure but let me just
let me just say it's 5% of the award so
the charter school is going to qualify
for 30% of the building Aid award it's
going to be determined that that is you
know $20 million uh whatever that um
turns out to be and then we'll pay the
state will pay $1 million for 20 years
uh so it won't have anything to do with
the depreciation of the building but I
don't know if that if that do you think
it's necessary that there be a sh Bond
or some kind of a I unfortunately I
don't know anything about shity
bones I've heard of them I guess what my
limited um you can confirm this
information I think you should but I
think that when you take out a bond it's
just a certain percentage like one or 3%
um of the project that um gives that but
again I'm sure if somebody's listening
there they might be shaking their head
so I guess that's all I'll say do you
know anything about that you were at the
meeting okay okay okay all right yeah
represent leus yeah I'd like to follow
up on the 5%
and it's 5% of the
30% and my question
is are they really gaining much
considering have you figured out the in
extra interest that will have to be paid
if you're only paying at that amount and
what interest rate they're paying on
their loan and by doing it by 5% are you
really
losing a bunch of that money I mean have
you figured out what what the money's
actually come to by the time you look at
how much more interest they have to pay
by only doing that versus the amount
they're actually
getting I haven't R run any calculations
so probably would depend the amount the
um rates but we certainly could run a
simple calculation but you know interest
on a $20 million is a lot of money right
over the course of the life of a bond
that's why
significant amount of money um it is the
old you know this is creates the tail
like that is how we used to fund School
construction projects uh is that the
state would pay 30% of the principal um
on the bond they would they've never
covered interest cost is always picked
up by the local right but what I'm
wondering is if you drop it down to the
5% of the 30% if all you're do if if if
that all gets eaten up in the extra
interest that they end up paying and you
might as well not give them anything oh
I I it would not we I can run a
calculation it's not um a good portion
of the amount no it's not like if you're
getting $20 million from the state
certainly in so um for easier numbers
let's say I know this numbers don't
fully match but 30% in thir let's assume
it was 33% because it's just easier if
they were had a $60 million project and
their award was $20 million they're
going to pay interest over that Bond
bond for $60 million all the way through
the 20year period that is going to
account for a substantial amount of
interest but it's not going to be 30% of
that 5% of 30% no it's um five so it's
um we make 20 payments so it's only 5%
because um it's five times 20 is 100% so
we're giving them 100% of the award
right so their award is calculated at
30% 100% of their award will be $20
million at the end of 20 years they're
going to get that full $ 20 million it's
just that we're going to fraction it out
we're going to pay 12th the first year
12th the second year 12th the third year
all the way to 20 years until they have
all of their money I got I got that but
they're going to be paying a lot more
interest because they were because they
now had to take out a much bigger loan
than they would have had to take out if
you paid it up front like we do with the
public school absolutely they will
definitely have why I'm wondering how
that how much they're losing by doing it
this way that's my question right yes
definitely more interest for sure
there's no doubt taking that out and not
getting your full amount you're going to
be paying whatever your interest rate is
on your bond you're be paying that um
paying it down so it is much more
beneficial to get 80% up front but it
wouldn't deter a school we can run those
numbers but I just want to be clear that
interest is not the full amount of the
award it's not even close but we'll get
those numbers thank
you that's exactly why we went to 80% to
take the interest off the communities
but what it did do it restricts the
number of app grants which because
you're paying it all out front of that
$50 million you have appropriated that
year which we only had half that amount
because of debt you you could only award
it to so many schools and and there is a
lot of discussion I've heard it from
folks sitting to my right here that if
we only paid out 40% or something
initially we could might be have enough
list it's going to have to make sense to
do something here because we have 17
schools remember that put in for
applications here that were on your list
we approved three of which one was not
approved by the
community and the others that are not
being receiving money have had to put
all this outlay out for their
engineering design their plans Etc and
they there's no predictability when they
might get an application approved they
may never see the gain from that money
isn't that why we're going to the pay
everybody a certain amount per year and
deal with that's the thought of one of
the bills coming forward but believe me
that is a very complex type
issue that is going
to require a lot of discussion and with
109 bills coming here I don't know how
we're ever going to have the time to do
it you know are they going to have we're
going to use this is Amy still going to
have to approve for Life Safety health
and all the criteria we have for the
design of a building or is that going to
be up to the locals to do what do what
they do with that money when can they
access this money who holds the money
the state or the local who gets the
interest on that money being held the
treasury or the
local can I also just put uh uh just be
because you mentioned a different
process I just want people to remember
that this house bill 452 just passed in
July so when people talk about problems
with building Aid this bill that passed
um um drastically improves the process
and um I'm excited about the process
because it got rid of a lot of uh
difficulties with that process there's
still a funding issue so don't get me
wrong but um but the bill that you've
amended here um seems to work if that
does change to 80% it it was amended
with the changes from 452 correct yes
that's why I took so we just I just got
this handed to me this morning Jeff over
there said this is a devil of a time
doing this because you know a lot of the
new changes have just been posted on
their online for them to access to make
these changes it was just posted this
last week
right
yeah representa Ellison then uh thank
you Mr chair uh I'm referring to page
five lines 35 to 37 uh and I just if
somebody could give me some sort of
information uh on how this would really
work it says projects that did not
receive approval from the state's
District's legislative body or the Char
school public school trustees May submit
resubmit those
projects I'm trying to figure out how
this might work if if a local school
board does not approve an
application to be sent forward it
appears to me that somehow that
application even though the School Board
didn't approve it could be resubmitted I
I'm not sure who would re who would
resubmit the application in that in that
case Amy can you explain what happened
with Co
Brook um well just in general terms um
because that wasn't the school board
that was the voters uh but the in
general terms I think that
um there's when you apply for building
Aid you submit a uh part of your
application that says the school board
um wants the district to submit that
they approve they're on board with the
school the school district and
everybody's on board uh and so if that
works out they might get funding if they
don't then the following year they um
are still going to be on that list and
so we just want to make sure that the
school board is still in favor of
keeping the project on the list and if
they don't uh the school board does not
agree then they get booted off the list
but that doesn't prevent them from ever
apply reapplying again okay so is C
Brook back on the they rejected it the
town rejected that was not the school
board that rejected it was the town
correct so the and we we are we're
looking at applications being submitted
annually now not by
annually so in the next
bium Cobra could come back correct
colber has applied for building Aid
their school board supported them their
application for a set amount of dollars
they have to site the amount of that the
project um is in their minutes um they
have not told us they're not interested
in the project so they'll remain on the
list until they don't um unless right so
I guess that will be the short answer to
that how long do they remain on the list
uh so they'll remain on the list um so
they'll remain on the list until we have
money to give them um and then their
voters approve the if we have if the
state has funds to give a school
district um
money let me back up if the state
doesn't offer the school district money
they'll stay on the list until we can
offer them money as long as their school
board says that they're still okay with
it they'll continue to stay on the list
because the state has never offered them
an award once the state has offered them
an award our draft regulations anyway
that are still going with this new
process will allow them to hold on to
that award three time three voting
Cycles before their voters would have to
reject it three times and then they
would get booted off the list and have
to reapply that I didn't know that part
and and it does seem like that that um
somewhat makes sense because there's
usually something significantly wrong
with the project that needs to be be
reworked with the community for them to
understand so you do get off the list if
your voters are not supportive of your
project um you also get off the list if
your project substantially changes so
unfortunately your voters could say no
and then you have to go back to the
drawing board and come up with a
different project then that also if it's
not substantially the same also falls
list followup uh let me get this clear
then if if the uh if they're on the list
they don't withdraw from the list and
they're going to stay on the list until
or they get State they get State money
is that that's basically what you're
saying or through a cycle anyway correct
so there be no need for the school board
to resubmit an application because
they're already approved and on the list
or approved to be on the list correct
correct thank you correct we'll have
some um we have some process to submit
um a way to update the um costs in that
application because you could be sitting
on that list for a while and every year
we'll ask for the school board
to send a letter that they still want to
be on the list but the application
itself just remains in
house further
questions yes representative dry thank
you very much um can you just clarify
for me if some school is kind of
treading water and staying on the list
how does that affect dispersement to
other schools like could another school
get on the list also is it Like An
accounts payable that we have to have
out there that's always going to be
year um can you say that again um yeah
if if if a if a disqual um rejected by
the voters or School District's approval
uh project is still on the list every
year until that it comes up is it does
that affect the amount that's available
to give to other schools the next go
around so um yes and no so um you're not
in this new one big correction with this
uh bill which is excellent is now when
we offer an award we have actually that
is from money that's already been
appropriated therefore schools are not
waiting to see what the state does so we
hand them a letter saying that we have
money for you um you can now go to your
voters and ask to see if they want to
approve the project um in that case that
money is tied up because were waiting to
see if the voters approve the project so
if the voters don't approve that project
that money is still tied up for up to
three year three voting Cycles um with
that particular project for that
particular project and if they then say
no three times or or yeah so if they the
voters then say no three times they'll
get booted off that list and that money
has not been sent spent we haven't
actually given them the money yet we
won't do that until the voters pass the
project and do some other things uh
a a fair amount of other things uh and
then that money would get returned to
right now gets returned to the state
which um is another big reason for um
having a dedicated building Aid non-aps
fund because the goal would be to take
those monies and put them back in then
you'd have more money to um rent to
offer to those people on the list thank
you and I'm I'm happy to without V
visuals we have a whole flowchart and I
realize um for this new process spe
specifically so I'm happy to have that
um conversation if you ever would like
it I know that you guys are really busy
but so a question for the committee just
stay where you are because there
probably question coming back we we at
the last
meeting I I heard folks saying that for
a Charter Public School to receive money
they had to own the building is that
where we are as a
committee for a charter school to get
renovation or construction money in
accordance with
1985 they had to own the building
because that's something right here that
this puts in that was not in the
original bill I don't believe it
was it I I will say just in general um
just in general building a is only
eligible to um if you own the facility
and then if it's not um then you have
lease Aid so it's either one or the
other so if you're leasing building you
qualify for lease Aid I'm not sure that
it would make sense to have lease
buildings be using State those State
dollars it's a separate appropriation if
you want to add anything just to add
that was in the original bill it looks
like you've preserved uh what would be
on the first page of your Amendment line
21 exactly as I have it in my bill you
have to own the building good good so
that that's that's a good hurdle there
and then within does then the charter
school who receives this are they going
to be accountable to Roman 3 which is on
page one and goes on for repayment if
they
desolve should they be held to the same
standard that the other public schools
are where they have to pay back a amount
which they have
received in this case they' be paying
back what they received less
depreciation I don't see why not I mean
we've have that um the draft has that in
there I think the original draft had
that in there it's we're just treating
the the significant difference is um
that the payment schedule everything
else is the same um and then the only
other things are when we're talking
about um District voters it's obviously
it's different for Charter Schools as
well now the other change here of course
we tried to do it in conjunction with 45
to this this the change is here what was
passed in hb2 I can't recollect uh
representative uh that what what part of
this is already
law um just to sort of retrace that uh
my house bill
354 verbatim was in the house version of
House Bill 2 the Senate took it all out
yeah I'm not sure what the discussion
was I a feeling it was related to the
bill you referred to that was passed
earlier this year uh but all of the um
original language of your Amendment
naturally is still law yeah but it looks
like you've done a great job of brushing
up the original House Bill five a 354
well I didn't do it the attorneys cross
street did it excellent job I would just
add two if I could you know I've heard
so many opinions on school building Aid
it's incredible everybody has a
different thought with regards to how
this should be done and I would just
simply say uh in the meantime let's just
include public charter schools in the
application process until Perfection is
reached on the perfect way to handle
School building Aid in other words let's
not let Perfection be the enemy of the
good here and furthermore your Amendment
not only incorporates the house adopted
version of House Bill 354 that was in
our version of House Bill 2 but it still
corrects the massive glaring discrepancy
in current law right now where one
section says Charter Schools do not get
school building Aid and another section
it says they get
30% that glaring conflict cannot stay
and your Amendment corrects that I would
ask the committee to adopt
it okay um further discussion from the
committee yes represent Cornell just as
a question how many Charter Schools do
own their own buildings now
that's 11 now okay thank you can can we
tell can we get that updated then you
know I can't I can't count 11 you know I
I've been trying to discern what is
least what is not what's not going
forward are these
11 that have been in business for at
least one year and because I I we're
basing Aid on the
average daily membership right not
residents because the the the building
Aid is for residents for a public school
but these this is
adma um just to clarify that's only true
in the C how you calculate their
building Aid rate Char schools don't do
that they just qualify for 30% the only
time average daily membership comes in
in Residence comes in place is the
calculation of the public school
districts building
rate yeah see there there was there was
an amendment put forth in division 2
last year which they used adma rather
than
admr but that was for that other program
I'm afraid that's that's haunting us and
it's going to come back so but so this
is based just
upon uh what because median so your
building Aid rate is based on median
family income in equalized valuation per
pupil that per pupil is where the admr
comes from um so that's why it's
important but that's only important when
you are calculating a building Aid rate
for Charter Schools you can't calculate
that so that's 30% at least that's 30%
of attendant or it's based on 30% of the
eligible project costs so it's just that
um you you have a project and you we
determine what is eligible um expenses
that U meet the uh regulations and the
project qualifies for 30% all the way up
to 60% school districts we calculate
that rate 30 to 60% for Charter Schools
we don't calculate that rate we just say
30% and it's 30% of the eligible project
costs or 40% of the eligible project
cost all the way up to 60% of the
eligible project costs do you do when
you're looking at the criteria for any
school for approval there are certain
minimum standards which you have in
rules square footage Etc mhm correct
does that is that applicable to the
charter
school it is I can't think of any um any
that wouldn't are all life health safety
related issues they're all things that
charer schools are having to meet anyway
uh we require our building to be ADA
Compliant public charter schools have to
be so then is that local that criteria
then that engineering criteria that you
use at all related to num students in a
classroom or the number of students the
school has correct it's all related to
enrollment or enrollment
projections okay so we're we're nearing
that point where AID may be based upon
attendance and do we have to before you
get renovation or construction do you
have to be in business for at least one
year uh we don't have that requirement
that you have to be a business one year
and I don't see that in the amendment uh
so but your formula for public school is
you take the
5year average to determine the building
okay any questions for either t or
Amy yes representative Ford thank you Mr
we're going to quit at 12:30 on this one
and take lunch I'm kind of hung up in
those kind of situations in which maybe
it's an issue of ownership literally or
whether there something like a charter
School wants to lease a building from
the school system which it does not need
at present but the school system doesn't
want to give up ownership of the
building in case the charter school
doesn't continue and wants it back how
then do we wind up with something in
this kind of a process
whereby you basically are renovating a
school in order to lease it to a charter
school which the community wants
everybody's in agreement with a goal MH
then how you use this mechanism to
achieve the renovation of the building
which should the charter school fail
will by contract revert to the
school that's a very good question um
probably something we should think a
little bit more about but um the uh but
it's the public school district that
would have to apply for that building
Aid because they are the owners of The
Bu The District because they're on paper
is the is the owner correct correct now
what's interesting though that question
is that does the charter school become
eligible for lease Aid because they're
leasing from the public school district
that received building Aid so it's a
very valid question maybe that is
something we'll have to take a look at
like are is the state paying lease Aid
on a space that was paid for by building
Aid is that is that kind of uh double
dipping I don't know that's a very good
question though but I do know in order
to get building a to renovate that
building it would have to be the public
school district that files that
application that's seems like a local
issue between the local school board and
the charter school that's leasing uh we
have here in the last page that the
state we were concerned about the state
not being liable for any of these other
assets which the charter school may have
encumbered during the time that they've
been in business and this specifically
says no the state won't be held liable
now the local school district who made
that lease they'd have to have that in
their lease agreement wouldn't they so
that's not really something when we're
talking about school building Aid which
we should be concerned about
here I'm not sure I'd have to think a
little bit I'd have to think that
through a little bit more we've never
had we've well first of all we've been
on a moratorium for 10 years so we've
all have only a handful of cases that
we've funded four school projects um and
that hasn't come up yet and it's a very
good question for us to think a little
bit more about the only area I know is
like winnisquam where they have that
empty building that's now charter
compass
that used to be a public school so in
that example that's maybe a good example
to talk about so that was Union sandborn
is that correct that's the school that
you're talking about so Union sorn
applied for building Aid um had they
received it their voter they were
actually I think vote ranked one on the
list if I recall um their voters did not
approve that project so we never um gave
state aid for it um but had we given
state aid for it and then later that
school Consolidated with the other
school that they they those kids now go
to um and sold the building to the
charger school or even even if they
didn't that would be a penalty for
repayment and we would have asked for
all of those funds back W Gan would have
had to pay that back correct they would
have
yeah any other questions for doe yes
represent Damon thank
you could you just comment in regards to
if this were to pass would the criteria
for Charter Schools applying for
building Aid be the same criteria as
public schools currently have and then I
have a followup oh absolutely there's
really no difference um the only
difference um in my um head that's going
to be um somewhat significantly
different is this payment the way we pay
them and what is that is going to do is
continue to create a tail it will be a
baby tail but it will be a tail um and
so that
may
make Charter Schools more likely to
receive building Aid even though it
sounds like a penalty because you're
paying for interest but because when we
we get building Aid in um we get an
appropriation every year so if that
appropriation happens to be I'm sorry I
always have to use numbers but if that
happens to be $30 million that we get
appropriated that year and we have a $29
million of projects that we offer too
there might be a sliver left that is not
attractive to anybody else but might be
very attractive to a a public charger
school um we might only have $400,000
left most people are going to bck at
that because they're they're looking for
full 80% and they may pass and stay on
the list because they're going to wait
another year and hopefully get offered a
full award and it might tell the charter
and that little
amount will trickle down um and it's
actually really beneficial not just to
Charter Schools but also um to smaller
projects we're now seeing we were a
little worried about smaller projects
not being funded with this system but
now it's kind of nice to see because
that little that little chunk that
schools are passing up on will mean
something to the smaller projects on the
bottom I don't know if that fully
answers your question but for me that
that's the only uh pretty big difference
but that Charter Schools will play in
this um in our process and it's because
of that payment
schedule the way this been written is
that they're accountable for everything
that a riger public school is
accountable for and we meshed it in with
our current
law um it's the payment and all that
that's different and then the other
difference is the voter you know the
charter schools aren't waiting for
voters to pass their project so um that
will be a you know when I said you hang
on to that award for three up to three
voting Cycles you know my expectation is
that charter school will be able to
start construction that very next year
I'm assuming that they'll have support
Trustees
yes so I appreciate what you just
explained and I think I understand it
um is it correct though practically
speaking since we have no history of
appropriating anywhere near the amount
of money that is requested for building
projects that essentially this
legislation would create a yet more
competitive environment for building Aid
in that Charter Schools applying for Aid
would be competing with the public
school projects that we already fund
only a token portion
of uh what did you say 11 11 schools I
suppose of all those 11 school yeah it
creates more there's more people that'll
Ed eligible so certainly one charter
school added to the list is going to be
one more school that's in front of some
other school um it just when you think
of percentages wise it's probably not
really that significant that not all 11
schools are going to come forward at
once um it's also when we talk about
that pot of money if we're only paying
them um that that we're putting them on
that tail appropriation they're also
taking less of that larger appropriation
so um um so but yes that's a fair fair
any competition they're all competing
other and the amount of money available
for uh building Aid is going to grow
because our tail is going down signif
and kind of rapidly here in another four
four years it drops sign other than
those couple payments are going to
string it out what 2 41
correct okay it's 12:30 and we need to
we need to take a break here at least
discuss where we're going is there any
more that anybody wants from the
Department right now or representa
Mooney thank you very much thank you
yeah or T and T if you could get back
those 11 schools that you have course we
appreciate
that would it also be of any value to
figure out with the 11 schools the the
values on their building or if they're
looking at potentially applying for
building Aid in the near future oh yes
yes defin defitely the values the
schools whether they're intending to do
it I also like to have their enrollment
numbers okay sounds good yeah great
thank
you so committee do you want to come
back in another half hour and trying to
get to another couple bills okay good
because we we need to I know that we
have one member has to get out of here
to go back to work for she loves to be
working she gets paid in that J she gets
paid she has paid for half and that's
the different parking tck okay thank you
very much so let's come back at 1:00 and
up
cleanup
I don't have an answer on this thing
right here now maybe what we ought to do
is hold off on this one and find out
from cordelli what that all was about
was this something put forth
know I I D is good it's yeah that's got
to that's got to be changed to
inclusive but the last part where
know oh it's been changed
[Music]
yeah
is I think if there's a a simple reason
why that's deleted and the doe or or
Glenn has a good answer then we can move
forward on it but I don't think we can
do anything right now so we ought to
jump over this postpone it to when we
meet
next I'm going to another
bill let's go on to uh 627 or or
um HB 155 I thought we had another bill
that's the shity
bond
more you know off hand I can tell you
why I have a hard time with this bill
right now because we're we're messing
around with the governance of higher
education and the higher education
commission which is that commission
which approves new institutions coming
in and it's diling from that one member
to be appointed by the governor and
Council as a representative from a
for-profit college University not a
member of the New Hampshire College
University Council that's eliminating
Darth that's eliminating um
uh numerous colleges in our our
state it's increasing from two to eight
the number of uh people from
postsecondary care
schools no what it's not going to eight
that's number eight they cross out the
eight
above
right
how many yeah let's take a straw boat on
this uh how many people just say we need
to it all the
bill
well there's other things they want to
change this
criteria the commission
shall regulate this and establish that
that's already all a lot of that's
already in law apply for accept and
expend state federal and other grants or
eliminating that
part
um
yeah
mhm I can tell you right now the
governance of all higher education under
the gun right now we're looking at that
trying to rewrite the whole thing and
that would include the higher education
commission which is made up of your
college
presidents and other people are coming
out of high it um I I don't think we
should be messing with that at this
time it's almost like a shotgun type
deal by doing it that way so I I feel
this right now we're looking at
governance I mean the chancellors we
have an interim Chancellor that's also
Chancellor of the University system is
also at the same time president of
unh so does that mean according to this
that the president of
unh um who with the others two
presidents for from
institutions see the president of the
University of New Hampshire on Roman
281 the the chancellor under three does
votes it needs a lot more work than this
bill does and we shouldn't be touching
out from what the trustees are doing
right now and the governor's doing and
there's a bill that's been put in to try
to push something to happen and I got
that in we'll probably pull that once we
get the emergency order put through so I
would say at this time this bill is
delving into something that the timing
right completely
different considerations and what sherad
just referred to first half B make sense
to me to prer acting on but on page
original that's forward that's a
different
consideration I thought that the concern
was that ifar school
closed the students enrolled would be
out their
investment and not
protected and that this was an attempt
to somewhat address
amount
right so it's less
prot 10% of what the annual gross
tuition for current Academic Year versus
student it's kind of standardizing it at
10%
um rather
place
your call has been forwarded to an
automated I just trying to get a hold of
Steve applebe because he could give us
an answer
ask the latter part of the
bill Steve's GNA call me right
back now what they gave us there was a
letter that went with
it it said on p on page three line 3 to7
you'll see language changes on the bond
amount requirements the thinking being
that the current Bond requirement is
potentially daunting and over wng which
potentially could be unnecessarily fatal
to an institution obligated to secure a
bond sufficient to reimburse the tuition
for any service contract which could
also be read as every service contract
the new proposed language is more
realistic and more manageable Steve or
Steve
app Steve can you hear me yes sir how
are you good Steve we're looking at
you're on speaker here in in uh in with
just some people here on the committee
and myself uh we're looking at
hp55 that's a bill that's relative to
the division of educator support and
higher education and relative to shity
and deification for private
post-secondary career
schools you wrote in a email to us in
response to myself and Dave
luno uh I am emailing to the to follow
up on Dave's request for information
regarding the higher education past
history regarding applying for ETC
grants on page two line 8 of the bill we
have checked back to 2016 found no
instances of commission conducting any
of these activities to go further we'll
take a number of hours off staff time of
Staff
time I would make one other suggestion
line 8 could be unstruck but page two
line e the commission shall could be
amended to read the commission may I
hope this information is helpful please
let me know how I can assist further
we're calling for
assistance
forward I think so
um you know the I know that there were
concerns around the shy shy and
dentification Portion for licensed
career schools and certainly that could
be struck um and brought back at another
time but I think that the makeup of the
higher ed commission should be adjusted
it hasn't been changed in many many
years and uh for example uh we no longer
have any for-profit private colleges in
our state yet there is an open seat uh
that has been now for seven years on the
commission because it's the own statute
um so I I think that that portion should
move forward if possible and I
completely understand concerns around
the career School portion um and if
that's that is I think uh less important
than adjusting the uh the commission
membership so what's the definition of a
for for-profit college or university
it's then it's not something like uh
Dartmouth or some of our other privates
in the state no so we only currently
have nonprofit colleges in our state the
last for-profit college that existed was
okay you have question are there any
other questions possibly for
Steve theity part was what we were
interested in what where the commission
says the commission
shall um and there's they're leaving off
one item out of that and you suggested
putting it to May item number four where
it says the commission shall apply for
accept and expend state federal or other
grants um why would that be scratched
out in this bill so our concern would be
legal's concern when I when I talked to
our attorney about it was it says shall
apply for Grants which grants are we
talking about there are hundreds of
higher red
grants potentially that we would be
forced to apply for that we never
applied for in the past we don't have
the staff to to complete those
applications um so so is not to preclude
us from possibly applying to one I that
was my suggestion May
saying it reads like we need to go out
and apply for every higher grant that
comes
along okay but do does the commission
apply for these grants or is it the
individual institution applies for
Grants institutions apply for Grants I I
was on the commission for 10 years
before coming to the department so from
my recollection and again we would have
to go to the archives to research this
that's why I only went back to 2016 but
my recollection I joined the Commission
in 2007 and I do not recall the the
commission ever applying for a grant
from
2007 okay are there any other questions
this yeah in New Hampshire and there's
they're all career schools okay uh
represent Tanner says that in looking up
for profit uh schools is it colleges or
University or schools it just says
Schools they're they're the career
schools okay they're talking about these
for-profit schools as being career
schools yes there are already uh seats
on the commission for licensed career
schools that is a separate category
okay okay so if you look at the
membership of the
commission right we say um nonprofit
College private for-profit college
career school you know they're different
categories of of
members and those those the career
schools could be nonprofit or for-profit
we don't make that distinction Curr need
statute
uh okay where it says that the
membership on this Commission
includes the the president of the
University of New Hampshire the
chancellor of the University system of
New Hampshire what are we doing when
it's one
person uh currently um the currently
cath Venture is filling the roll the
chancellor position interim Chancellor
interim Chancellor right so um but again
that's where I think that in the
proposed legislation we had a
design language for some of these and
that would help us in this situation we
did it for the the bill does it for the
community college but not for the
University
system or do it
should okay I think for both of the
chancellor positions we also wanted to
add or designate okay just in case we
get into this situation
again okay so in looking at this bill if
we made those changes there that we you
just spoke
of and went along with eliminating
for-profit College University and change
may if we passed that part of the bill
and scratched everything doing with aury
demn ification is that along with what
you're trying to
okay any further comments from the
committee on
that I think we we look like we're good
Steve okay okay sorry I can't be there
I'm at New England Board of higher
education well have
bye gota be there too pardon me I have
to be at I was supposed to be at one of
the nebby meeting cons also I don't so
was L he didn't go either nobody's going
anymore who wants to go to Boston for a
nebby
meeting all righty so straw um are we
willing to take the part about 21
inclusive keep that in
there and
then no that's a different bill that's a
different Bill EXC me I got so on this
bill
155 making the change where it says the
Chancellor of the University system of
New Hampshire or
design that way Kathy prenter who used
to be the state treasurer who's now the
interim chancelor could be that
person
um and then eliminating line 15 16 as it
struck
out and then at the top of page two the
commission sha May sh to
May taking that strike out for number
four and then ending that online
everything from 29 onwards except for
the effective date which would you have
to change well would would be the
that everything at the bottom of page
two and all of Page Three except for the
effective date do we want to change at e
the sh to May or do we want to leave sha
for those other things and do May for
one I me are there because it seemed
like he would yeah it seemed like he was
just saying May for the for line four
yeah yeah but sh he didn't but not for
the
rest how about if I give this to Steve
and have Steve clean it up and I'll
mention that fact
and then when we do the other ones we'll
have something in front of us just go
right through it good y okay let's move
on to the next
Lea this looks like another sb266
bill it's the one where they're
modifying 193 c e h and k this one
modifies
H well I didn't choose what part should
be
modified um this may not be the best
place to put this that was one of the
things we were going to determine
is where it should go I didn't pick the
where I was just trying
to we talked about there should be
accountability there should be
accountability there was no
accountability there was all kinds of
arguments as to what the accountability
should be and where in the bill that was
put forward by I believe representative
luno but I'm not sure there was
accountability in that and he was very
proud of that and I thought well what if
I just take that accountability that he
put in his
bill um and see how that flies and so I
took this almost word for word straight
out of that bill that was submitted year
before
last and that was that was the point
um but as I said it ol picked where it
went I'm not not sure that that's where
go and so the question is are people
not we we've been just working on you
know remember Nate came in and Caitlyn
dealing with this 193
H and we looked at remember the
graduation rates and what would have
happened to those schools drop the
support they get from the federal
plan
um and we went with that shorter version
because we just didn't have the time to
do 266 everything in it I think we're at
the same point on this well that's what
I'm I'm wondering I mean and this may
have nothing to do with h that's just
where they put it it it might best be
put some place else um
but as I said this was straight word for
and actually there was a note that
instead of being after
H4 it should go after that somewhere
rather than
replacing
H4 perhaps in
six I don't know but yeah it'll take
some work so are people wanting to do it
or not is their interest in even passing
it or
not I put it in because we were trying
to come up with accountability and I
figured if that was already in a bill
that half of the committee supported you
there
them well there's one coming up that's a
193e but I don't think we should be
messing around with inadequate education
either at this point in time I think
that it's it's not going to gain us a
thing um because we've just recently
addressed that by modifying some of the
required subject areas like personal
finance literacy on H where you talked
assessment I I would think that the
legislative oversight committee may want
to deal with that uh because that's that
that committee's task with 193c and
H and we that's for oversight of how we
have accountabil
ability and they have statutory
authority to do that and that's another
one of our
it I think you can see right on if you
have your Green books on page
571 it says in addition to the
requirement of paragraph one schools
shall meet performance-based indicators
under this chapter and Statewide
performance targets new Mission targets
as approved by the Legislative oversight
committee and so probably the
legislative oversight committee you know
we could you
know could inter room study it or or
just you know make a recommendation that
that other committee look into this and
come up with some recommendation we're
doing the same thing right now with the
stuff which is this is one of the
chapters which that bill was trying to
address and the compromise with doe was
we'll put your two pages in there but
we're not going to do the 24 pages of
two
266 so maybe we gotta be working a
little bit with Nate on some of this as
well and with Caitlyn and with the
oversight
committee
yeah uh this
chapter uh deals with school Improvement
uh with targeted support yeah um um and
it seems like this is from ESS or a um
that it that it was designed to work
with targeted schools whereas the bill
that we're looking at is like um
oversight so I don't think you can I
don't know as you can change a lot of
Essa
well we talked about that we couldn't
change some things like the percentage
numbers because of the funding yeah um I
really do believe that this is should go
to legislative oversight which is got
act I I you know for us to do something
right now and doing this after we've
already said on 266 we're not going to
go with it now to go with it and format
I think it might be contrary to what we
said although it's a good thing it needs
to be done we need to get on top of a
accountability you know a a 56%
graduation rate even if you add the I
adequate so how do you
assess it's not necessarily through a
Statewide assessment either there's
other ways of doing
that but we have law has to be an
objective
assessment I I think
basically if we itl it we make a
recommendation that the purpose the
intent of this bill be directed directly
to the oversight committee to delve into
this subject area and that something we
can do yeah oh yes send it to them well
you can start that right off I'm fine
is everybody pretty agreeable to
that okay let's let's do that I don't
see anybody objecting to
it so that takes us through everything
we did
today when's a good date that's good for
people to get together it's getting hot
room what well we have to you know make
some you know we have some amendments we
want to put together we got to make a
recommendation to the supposedly the
full committee this is a committee the
whole to the full committee so we should
come forth with a recommendation so all
these things which we've been addressing
we got to do that the next committee the
whole we could make some of those
recommendations for the the committee
that we meet in November probably the
second week there of November yes
ofation
Cary of The Mountain View Culinary
Academy we are also aware of the
importance
of the tourism industry in our County
and the serious need for qualified
restaurant staff it is our understanding
they have been working with you and
other department of education staff to
secure their necessary license to open
but that an adequate charity bond is the
sticking point the problem seems to be
the cost of the requested $100,000 is
difficult for the Academy is our hope
that the amount of the required Bond
might be reduced to allow the academy to
get their license and then apply for
Grants since statute RSA 188 G3 only
requires a bond in the amount of 10% of
the gross tuition income we ask that you
re-examine the amount of the bond that
will be
required um that um Academy never did
open so I don't know what the what the
actual sticking point was so my idea of
a Shorty Bond is that it's like an
insurance that you buy so you're if
you're covering $100,000 you're not
paying $100,000 to the insurance company
uh you're paying uh
for an amount so to say that they were
stifled by
$100,000 uh I don't know if that's what
they would have had to put out I doubt
very much if that's what it had to be it
would be much much less to get the bond
there's other ways of doing it too like
a letter of credit yeah or you could
have an account set up with a local bank
yeah
um yeah if for $100,000 you could
probably get a bond and much much less
oh yeah it's under $100
right represent dry thank you I if we're
going to talk about the shity things I I
really um our practical experience in
our family was I had a son at MacIntosh
college that was in the col the chef's
coron blue Chef's class uh he was the
last class before it closed if he was
able to graduate but there was a very
real possibility that he would lose the
investment that he had made because
Macintosh wasn't folded into the
university system and actually had to
close its doors so the idea of refunding
the tuition is important I mean that's
important to students and we have an
example in New Hampshire in the recent
past
so so I'm thinking I I would I'm glad
we're cutting that out but I think if we
approach that in the future um we really
have to Compare the numbers that they
were asking for compared to what's in
there
now well it's not eliminating insurity
Bond it was
modifying
yeah
yeah right it went it went from covering
the estimated to tuition costs for that
year to down to 10% of
it and I think it's important to keep it
the way it is and not take that that out
well I think that's a great idea yeah
the kid should get back yeah what they
put
in I think it would be strengthened if
you specified that that has the priority
because what happens in that chaos is
other people start grabbing it any money
that's available so you have to SP ify
the priority compensation first will go
to the demn ification of the students
you really have to spell it out because
it'll pay 100 hands grabbing for that
money and they'll all have lawyers but
that's why in the other Bill the
dissolution of
Charters it said that those other assets
no we're not going to be liable for that
and the state wants its money paid back
on that state
allocation for that exact reason and I
think that's a good good policy have in
place so I would leave it the way it is
[Music]
meet
y
that's
o'clock yep that's full on the 12th we
got yeah the 36 in the morning and
depending upon what we're
told you know we will handle the mental
health bills if they're scratching all
306 just on on that day yes because if
we're going to do it right we shouldn't
have Fred in here for a half hour an
separate if it's
necessary if it's necessary um I don't
know what Fred's going to present to us
but we got two hours to hear that then
we'll have an hour break and then we'll
have the three bills to take up and
based upon what we hear in the morning
it will help us make a decision in the
afternoon if he's taking mental health
out of
306 means our afternoon work is going to
be a little bit more
coming no no that was going to be a
followup if depending upon where we
go yeah I talked to Mel about that on
the horn the other night that we want to
really that morning have brat in he
takes that much time in some of those
hearings and talk about the people who
were involved in developing the B6 PL
and what competencies are talk about
what's in the plan
yeah so just to know representative
Tanner and I both heard Christine Donley
present in planfield a couple weeks ago
she was very formative I really think we
would all get some perspective from her
if we had the opportunity I would
happily engage with her
again I doubt very seriously if we're
going to have all the mental health
stuff done that quickly and that's the
12th and we still have several weeks
following in the month to wrap it up
that's when Christine would come in I
wasn't necessarily saying on the 12th
yeah just saying it would be good for it
to
happen
so to for us to meet again and try to
get some recommendation you get these
amendments made you're going to have to
have some time to throw an amendment
today is there any time in that week of
the
16th
I'm not I got a university trustee
meeting on the 19th and the 20th and I'm
speaking at grony Center to the social
subte on
18 yeah that was just came out
right what about the
16th
no that's right that's the New Hampshire
fiscal policy istitute are you going to
be there from 8 to
4 I'm not I going to be there eight to
four
no but it's about education and child
care
okay representative are we able to be
here late when there's subcommittee
schedule like on the 18th subcommittee
scheduled I can't make that time but can
I come later what time's the
9:30 could come in the afternoon I mean
I probably get here by late morning so
I'm just curious whether I can come
because
some sometimes you can't
come oh no
forgiveness
I couldn't hear you over here I was
going to say well if I got here late for
what's already scheduled you could
technically already be done by the time
I get here so I'm suggesting maybe
in that meeting starts
at I know I've had have to ask Ruth
Ward but I I don't think it's really uh
going to be a long meeting at all so I
could even skip it come get something
done
here maybe the afternoon session like at
12:30 1:00 depending on what other
people
think what time can you get
on
hours what 12:30 Pard me 12:30 yeah yep
that would work well how about everybody
else if we get on
we have some things where we could just
yeah
yeah starting at 12:30 because we have
subcommittee in the
morning but not everybody's on there
then because we've done a lot of work
today so we just come in that wrap these
things up make
recommendations that will be all
them no we have 20 retained bills how
right no but we've had a show of hands
right but what I want to do is just put
those down where we've had these show of
hands and take all those at one time
here like on 18th to 12:30 and just walk
through
them we agre yeah we'll have minute
rules one minute to
[Music]
right
but yeah you know she's been here before
and she didn't put her hand up at all
[Music]
today this is this is like the time
hearing a
bill me unless asking people from there
it's not another here and this is the
The Advisory Council this bill shouldn't
be hanging us
there
[Music]
we are testimony this morning from two
State reps two people that have been on
the committee for about 20 years someone
from the Department of Education and
none of them seemed to have that opinion
um of why it's not working right so I
it we we' we've had this discussion in
numerous bills remember the special
education Advocate through HHS
and and there was a a problem in hiring
that advocate The Advocate has now been
hired I understand that's where a lot of
the issues that parents have can be
directed in that direction now
um I for one thought we were getting
pretty close to getting this thing
resolved
um yes we did discussion that we had
perhaps
to oh she did that already
today
okay
and
[Music]
aspect of it not the health specific
treatments but
inter
that apparently we are live and Glen
anybody well let's go down through 147
one more time then here here's what we I
think which we all agreed upon we agreed
that oh before I say it why don't we let
the people are going to write tell us
what we
correct Mike Mike yep we agreed to one
Senator yes uh let me get I got it here
we agreed to two representatives of
which one would be from the education
yep use your
mic uh the other piece of it was um
allowing parents to serve dual roles yes
we kept the um and that was going to be
information we got back from Rebecca
right whether we could do that or not um
it reduced it to one teacher uh it added
back disabilities rights Center in the
parents information center we're down to
one
student and the correction we added the
correction officers right kept the
correct both we have to do F because it
said it it was required by the
idea I have I have a question about that
one Margaret okay stop with f okay for a
second
Katie because if you look at the
um this from idea which it say and under
membership it says
state state number five state and local
education officials including official
who carry out activities under subtitle
B of title 7 I'm wondering
if um
on if we're looking at chap uh
186 um line E and F if that's the
same like if it's redundant so if one
one State education official and one
local education official is the same as
state and local education officials line
five on the
three the membership requirements under
ieda is there argument was that it says
officials and that's why we needed two
and not just one that was their argument
so I had that we crossed out the one
local education official who shall be an
administrator appointed by the governor
I have that we cross that out is that
not
right keep it keep it they wanted to
keep that I wanted to keep it both
because in what representative pedal
just referenced it says officials and it
also says state and local it doesn't say
local
and we we didn't
decide we decided not to have a
clerk um I didn't get I don't think we
had a really lot of discussion a clerk
is somebody that can be appointed well
from a member that's there Katie yeah
Katie was saying that if we what they
wanted was a clerk from the Department
of Education which was estimated at
$50,000 no no no no what they're trying
to decide is that was an OP that was a
possibility but but this would say the
chair you elect the chair and the clerk
just like you do on here and that was
what they sounded said yes as long as we
clerk which is the which they could do
right now right exactly have a stat say
we're going to have a secretary or
whatever well you know it's been it's
been a difficulty and I think they think
this solves a problem they have a
CLK
yeah I think it was just an attempt to
solidify that the clerk was somebody
nominated from that committee anded and
that in the past there had been an
attempt to find an doe employee to take
the minutes and that this would
eliminate that occurrence in the
future um apparently when they
reorganized last night it was done by
the committee so I don't have that
history I can only go judge by going
happening well really doesn't make any
difference whether it's in or out you
know a committee can do it or you can
put it here and they they'll still do
the same thing it be elected by the
majority people in the
counil but if we do it here then they
won't have that discussion in the future
of wanting somebody from outside because
they'll know it comes from them right
we're not we're not trying to run the
meeting for them I know we're just
trying to make it less it it it will
eliminate like Alicia's correct them
from requesting Monies to have somebody
to take the
notes because to be elected from a
Council are we still on G did we put
teachers I think that was a required
required
yeah so you have to have two so that has
to go back in that was they were trying
two and what about t did we keep the
health provider in
there
yeah but remember I think the a little
bit more in the majority sorted taking
it out
10 yeah but it was pretty even yeah I
would like to discuss that before we
vote on that again as to why to leave it
in they're saying they don't need it
because they don't need to hear from
them because they can call an expert but
that wasn't why they were put in there
to begin
with
I'm wondering if the Le uh medical
person should not be an advisory member
of the committee therefore calls upon
just to rule on is this good health
practice or
not I don't think that was that was not
the that was not the point well I
thought it was I thought it was
important that they have that ability to
get that advice and that knowledge but
remember I said one local Health
provider who shall specialize in working
with children such as a pediatrition
appointed by the governor as a nonvoting
member right um I guess
there's in talking to various of the
people including Moren afterward I
mean Kaitlyn thank you
afterwards
um the people who were here at the desk
we're looking at it as in what do they
need and they can go out and
get uh special you know they can invite
people in but this was there was a need
and I guess it was more
complicated partly to get the the
information back to the
pediatricians from there just like we
want somebody on their committee to
who's part of Education to come and tell
us what going on so that was part of it
but part of it I guess there is quite a
bit of issue with legal paperwork
information all kinds of stuff that
they're running into problems with and
having
somebody and it doesn't have to be
specific to a
particular disability but somebody who
has to deal with all of that stuff the
legal issues and all of that having them
on the committee to bring up up those
issues and that's one of the one of the
things I guess that's been a problem
that that um is the other part of the
reason why they put that in
government I don't
know well the impression I got was the
I don't know if we all are at the same
meeting this
morning as I said I talked to a bunch of
them afterwards including Caitlyn kutab
who was telling me why they had put that
in there and it wasn't what the people
who we spoke to who sat at the desk it
wasn't what they were looking at that is
not why she put it in and so they were
looking at two different completely
different reasons for having a
physician why don't you get two
amendments made one with it in one with
it
good count all the number of people at
the table here and we're spending hours
here
yeah
why don't we say none of their meetings
can last more than 30 minutes period
that's it no matter what you decide I
don't care 30 minutes you're donee
represent albon and Tanner are you got a
handle what you guys supped has to do I
hope so good thank you is there any
other
discussion meting
12:30 as
pardon
me it will be a subcommittee meeting
you're welcome to get a sub if you so
desire um 12:30 official vote the the
final vote the final vote will be in
November this is like a subcomittee only
it's a subcommittee of the
no yeah but I think everybody has to
know there will be a vote
taken so that you know if like we have
one two three four five Empty Chairs
here
today but I I don't think it's made much
today no but I agreed we wouldn't
so let's let's just do our voting at
12:30 on the 19th on 18 18th Wednesday
18 let me write it
down
okay after we just
have
there'll be some days there might be
some other subcommittee meetings that
you know there's Glenn has a couple
going
on uh there are a couple that I had um
which were Committees of
whole and they bring forward that stuff
at the same time 12:30 just dump it all
done
okay know thank
you
working I think we're
done thank you very
this are a military we've been done five
hours
ago oh
yes Mr chair are we having a
caucus